so Joe Biden has rejected a meeting with
Democrats who are concerned over what's
happening on the border at the same time
we've got news that CBP apprehended an
actual terrorist suspect and released
him and now we've got uh information
that ice has arrested the individual but
it's kind of insane that that could even
happen how is it happening well we've
got a viral video where it appears it's
being reported the federal government
has deployed a back loader to lift up
razor wire to allow illegal immigrants
to flood in through the southern border
and it's just insult to injury so we
we'll talk a lot about that plus we got
a bunch of other stories it's Friday
we're chilling we're just going to jump
into it before we get started I want to
give a shout out to one of our members
foxglove and associates.com this is a
member of timcast and on Friday as we
shout out our members if you want these
awesome leather products beautifully
made we at this Expedition gear we've
got these nice little bags pouches look
at this this guy is very Dapper head
over to Fox Glove and Associates check
out their products and support
businesses that agree with and support
your values that's what it's all about
so uh shout out to Fox gloves and
Associates actually I think I got to put
the link in the description I'll get
that in there in a second but uh shout
out to our members every Friday we uh we
we just shout out uh uh we get one of
the members and we say like here's their
website because you guys support us we
support you so uh don't forget to also
head over to
timcast.net our work directly if you
like what we do there's no members only
on censored show tonight but those are
typically Monday through Thursday you
don't want to miss it you can call in
and talk to us on our guest but it's
Friday so we're going to be chilling
tonight talking about uh you know just
all sorts of stuff so smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all the this and a
whole lot more is Dave de Camp Tim
thanks for having me my name is Dave de
Camp I'm the news editor of antiwar.com
that's where you can find all my writing
I also host the daily podcast called
anti-war news with Dave the camp it's
basically 25 minute uh rundown of all
the top foreign policy stories of the
day from our anti-war
non-interventionist perspective uh I got
a YouTube channel it's called anti-war
news go over there and subscribe and uh
yeah that's all my work and uh end all
Aid to Israel all right on figured I'd
throw that in there throw it in there
fair enough I am uh Phil leonti a very
failed singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counterrevolutionary
I'm Ian Crossland hello everyone and I
want to give a shout out to gamer Maids
the newest show on the timcast network I
popped in and played some uh party
animals Animal party I think it's called
animal party earlier with uh Chris Sarah
and Charles it was high high impact high
energy go check it out gamer Maids on
YouTube and give it a subscribe okay
hold on gamer you know g m e r and Maids
as in people who clean your house that's
what I said gayer Maids right yeah game
I just wanted to spell it for people who
are wondering what the URL might be
gayer Maids gamer Maids gamer Maids
check it
out uh I sure will check out gamer mer
ma love
it sounds good uh yeah I'm surge.com
guys I just got to say like you know
branding is supposed to be memorable and
easy to convey and just how this got
approved it's entire I went to chat and
I was like where are the mermaids this
is this is an adult show so right this
is not an adult show this is a family
show so I don't want to talk about what
I'm thinking with that that well so fun
Ser just here are we going to jump into
the news then yeah yeah yeah all right
here's here's the story but it's not the
story the story is this Biden declines
meeting with Dem Mayors demanding action
on Border CR
yeah yeah yeah we get it Biden doesn't
care let me give you the actual story
here's a video Texas installed a border
fence to keep illegal migrants out the
federal government came in and lifted it
to allow hundreds of illegal immigrants
to pour in they say it's not a crisis
it's an invasion can I get this uh video
there you go I I am I am this is like
this is crazy when did this
happen let me turn that down so th this
is just first let me just let me just
say what the
this is clearly a video that appears to
be Eagle Pass I'm not entirely sure we
we we are not we don't have the exact
location or whatever confirmed but you
clearly have CBP trucks there and a
backloader lifting up the razor wire
allowing this is hundreds of people what
in the actual hell how it is mindblowing
that the federal government is lifting
up breaking the law lifting like not
only do they not enforce the law but
they're breaking the law aiding and
abetting people that are breaking the
law this is mind blown I just want to
stress this once again and you know
we'll definitely tie in Aid to Israel
with it all too the federal government
hates you they are taking your money and
your savings they are spending it on
money to blow up kids and they are SP
spending it to facilitate criminal
activities in this country when okay I
just what would you call it if members
of your own of of individuals in your
own government are giving resources and
material Aid to people who are not
citizens in order for those people to
break the laws of your country yeah I
think that's treason it might be treason
but they're not we're not at war with
these people so maybe not but once again
to bundle bundle all of it up together
just to make it we'll make it anti-war
too yeah we we they're not taking care
of us if you're on the left ask yourself
why you don't have health care okay if
you're on the right ask why it is your
savings is your your buying power
continually goes down it doesn't matter
who you are or what you want
we can all agree the first step is these
people need to be stopped we need to get
them out of government we need to we
need we need law enforcement to stop
people who are committing crimes this is
like okay treason and I don't have the
whole definition of the word treason but
it's the crime of attacking a state
authority to which one owes Allegiance
the federal government owes its
allegiance to the state of Texas it owes
its allegiance to every state in the
Union and if it's violating Texas law to
in incite criminals uh that's treasonous
in my opinion that just a sentence of it
I don't know do we know anything more
about this like when this happened or
who ex this this has been ongoing there
was actually the bigger story was that
CBP was snipping the razor wire yeah
remember that and this is a component of
that okay so I'm assuming this video is
probably recent considering this whole
Eagle Pass thing has has been going on
in the past several weeks but and then
is there ever any explanation like CU I
remember seeing the Snipping have they
ever said anything about that they they
claim that they're legally obligated to
allow people into the country to apply
for Asylum or something like that wow
but here's the issue if here mhm
allowing them the the argument is once
they cross the middle of the river now
that they're in America they can't be
deported and I'm just like yeah I don't
buy it because I think it was Texas that
put the buoy uh barrier in the water and
they came and said you got to get that
out now it's like well hold on when you
put it in the water you say nope it has
to go when you put it on land you say oh
well they're already here M we is this
confirmed that this is actually this is
exactly what we think it is because I
see a lot of fake videos these days fair
point
but I mean this is this is a CBB truck
okay so this is uh aen B Cabello citizen
journalist document the document IM
migrant journey and he says Eagle Pass
Texas Texas State versus Federal battle
continues this time with forklifts this
is November 2nd La last week the federal
government used a forklift to raise wire
and let 300 migrants in so I don't
believe it's a forklift I it's I believe
it's a backloader I could be wrong I
remember I saw a video recently of
people like putting cardboard and stuff
under the bar wire crawling and then
they actually made them turn around and
go back wow but that again that was just
kind of a random video on Twitter
there's another there's another video
where border patrol opens the gate at
the Ballard fencing and lets people in
and they're just like and I'm just like
what this is why they got so mad when
Trump said build a wall they W before
before Trump said we're going to go ham
on the border these people were just
coming across and what was happening is
really interesting they weren't
reporting apprehensions because there
weren't any so when they say there were
only 50,000 apprehensions immigration
was low no it was probably 550,000
illegal Crossings and only 50,000
actually apprehended When Donald Trump
started apprehending apprehension
Skyrocket and they said see it's getting
worse under Trump now we can see what's
going on you're right they're not being
apprehended they're being welcomed in
and we do know the Biden Administration
was trafficking children I want to
stress this statement of fact the Biden
Administration statement of absolute
fact trafficked migrant children have a
nice day they're helping blow up
children in Gaza right now
too that's fair and they're also blowing
up children in many other countries yeah
right let's let's we I'm not biased we
can't be biased about one yeah I mean uh
Yemen secret war in Yemen I mean that's
been ongoing for a really long time but
I guess uh who is just saying that the
the crisis has only just ended probably
because the US is Shifting all of its
resources to in Yemen yeah well there's
been a ceasefire between the houthis who
control most of North Yemen and the
Saudis who the US was backing in that
war which is a very brutal War there's
been a ceasefire that held since April
2022 relatively well there hasn't been
any air strikes there's been fighting at
the border but now you have the houthis
fire missiles at Israel and things could
get you know it puts the Saudis in a
Dave spot I don't care okay we should
not be funding it right we should not be
involved in this stuff we shouldn't be
but we are I know that's the thing
that's why we need to care because to
the houth cuz you might not care not
many people are aware but if you read
houie media every attack every bombing
every shelling is not just the Saudis
doing it they call it us Saudi
aggression so but I'll clarify I'm kind
of being a dick I of course care about
War I don't want I don't want it to
happen but I think the US makes it worse
you're right and then they're spending
my money to make it worse and we had
this we had an excellent amazing
conversation this morning with step
Marsh on the culture war and uh we were
basically just like the you the what
what stepen said something like the us
if you're going to go up against the US
military you're in trouble and I'm like
why they lose every war but they win the
engagements that's a horrifying thing to
say the US can actually blow you up
successfully but they can't maintain
control it just falls apart they don't
have like War goals I haven't seen like
a legitimate War goal from the United
States government they just want to keep
the wars going since like World War II I
mean there hasn't been a war legal War
in the United States since World War II
have none of them declar Vietnam I don't
know what the purpose of that war was
they never really if that Conflict
Vietnam was it to get oil they never
really said stop communism containment
was to it was to contain Communism
because they were they were considered
it the Domino Theory which was as
countries fell to Communism more
countries would fall to commun that's
like a never- ending thing so that's not
really a war goal ended kind of it was
it was it was a proxy war with with the
Soviets and I think they were trying to
get Malaysian oil and they just haven't
never want to tell they won't say that
out loud a lot ofion they tried to World
War I World War II and the Cold War were
all basically the same thing obviously
the right so the so Vietnam is a
component of the US was at war with the
Soviets but we were all scared if we
engage in direct conflict nuclear
weapons will fly so we did these we're
we're in with war in Vietnam and it it
was really Soviet and communist Chinese
interests well you see what they're
doing in Ukraine they they use the same
justification the claim is that if Putin
isn't stopped in Ukraine he's going to
roll into Eastern Europe but that's just
complete nonsense yeah nonsense doesn't
even cut you got you got to do the
narrator meme he would not yeah he would
not but you know John mimer he's the
international relations Professor the
realist guy uh his lectures you know
really popular on YouTube he talks he
was always warning for years and years
that the US in the West Was going to
provoke a war in Ukraine he always says
that before 2014 the coup in Kiev and
the Civil War in the dbass and Russia
annexing Crimea he said before that they
never said Putin was you know trying to
go into Europe that was never a talking
point then all of a sudden he became
this guy who wanted to reinstate the
Russian Empire and you know roll into
Poland but it's just a nonsense talking
point Putin I think three or four weeks
ago maybe a month and a half ago was
like the collective West has lost its
mind or the West has lost its Collective
mind it was just a hilarious statement
he's just looking at it like what in the
hell is doing he's right I don't think
he's a good guy but he's
right I'm it's so weird like oh jeez
dude we how do we strip this apart the
the the the bifurcation in American
politics is is just so insane the uh the
the there's no unification on on what
this country should be doing there are
people who are holding on to the last
vestiges of the American constitutional
republic there's a lot of them but then
I think the average run-of-the-mill
person doesn't know where care and then
the left is act actively seeking to
subvert I think what we're seeing with
the uh we talked about this this morning
again uh you know Steven mentioned that
the United States was born of rebels and
that Rebel mentality exists within our
do doents our documents were written by
rebels and we maintain that even through
the Civil War it all makes sense right
and uh and and then Phil brought up
exactly what the government is doing I
said they're trying to Stamp Out The
Rebel Spirit which is a component of why
they're like get as many non rebellious
people to come into the United States
and that will start to erode our ideals
that's part of the thing one of the
things that I'm concerned about with uh
not just with cbdcs like Central Bank
digital currencies but also with the
idea of um basic minimum basic living
Universal basic Ubi um when people are
are on the government
payroll and everyone is on the
government payroll that really is going
to make
people completely subservient now
there's still people that are like I
don't need the government I don't want
to deal with the government all I want
to do is live my life in a way that is
as independent as possible if you have a
cbdc definitely if you have some kind of
UB bi there's going to be so many people
that are just completely and totally
dependent on the government more so than
now now most people in urban areas most
people in cities are are on some level
dependent on the government even if it's
depending on the government to make sure
that they can get out of their driveway
if it snows or you know to make sure
that they have water and and and SE uh
sewage plumbing and stuff like that um
but if you have people that are getting
a
Ubi everything is going to be dependent
on the government every all of their
income all that means that you're
dependent on the government to eat but
realistically the moment the Ubi goes
into effect the economy spirals out of
control and within a month there's no
economy at all I I strong yeah I just
saw that uh we what do we print a
trillion dollars in the last three
months a trillion yeah it's crazy I
think it took 250 years to get to the
first trilli and what was it uh 80% is
just specifically for ziny himself
personally just just going bot mansion
and a big boat his cat Biden's asking
for $105 billion to fund the war in
Ukraine the war in Gaza to give military
aid to Taiwan so they could work on
provoking another war in Southeast Asia
and there is some for border security
that to entice the Republicans but right
it's just an insane amount of money $105
billion but I love this Biden's like we
need money for Ukraine and and Israel
and Taiwan and the border and the border
and the Republicans are like border
border can I go to my
bu I'm looking at the US national debt
clock oh we're going to say about I was
say taiwan's the crazy thing because I
don't know how the US maintains a
conflict with a with an island 90 miles
off the coast of mainland China yeah I
don't know but I what you do man I've
heard rumors that there are uh that the
United States has uh Special Forces
there yeah we have a few they recently
sent a few hundred troops to Taiwan it's
really the highest troop level since the
US and China normalized relations
because part of that deal was for the US
to pull its troops out and its Mutual
defense treaty with Taiwan and
eventually sto selling them weapons but
the way they made that commitment was so
vague that they'll tell you they can
interpret it in 12 different ways but uh
big part of it was pulling the troops
out and recently the US sent about 1 to
200 troops which doesn't sound like a
lot but if you're China you know it's
very provocative to China and you
mentioned sustaining a war yeah real
quick make a point imagine if China
stationed 100 troops in Cuba yeah China
has has actual police forces inside the
United States that's a good point I mean
like actual like they're not policing
regular Americans but they're policing
Chinese Americans what's the story with
that cuz I've
heard like I think them calling it
police stations is a pretty uh like
dramatic way to describe it's it's it's
it's Chinese law enforcement operating
out the United States with offices to go
to Chinese citizens living in the United
States and arrest them for crimes
against China from what I understand
that's not what it is I again this is
something I don't really know FBI said
thought it was okay I'm not a big fan of
the says a lot of things yeah from what
I understand they have these kind of
like uh offices where they that are you
know on on paper you know they they say
that they're there to help Chinese uh
Americans like with certain documents
and stuff and then they might be going
after dissident through those offices
yeah which a lot of countries do I mean
India might have killed a seek in Canada
you know if that was China that killed a
weager in Canada we would be talking
about that every day yeah but India kind
of you know the US is looking at India
as this new partner in containing China
this is from New York New York Post says
that they've opened four police stations
Chinese in North America three of them
are in Toronto one's in New York City
but you I I know they do what does that
mean police station to to Target Chinese
Americans for for in who knows so maybe
one thing on paper and another but I
want to stress this I think it's fair to
say that there's definitely a a very
warped perspective on what China is like
from for Americans yeah and I think uh
we we often get people saying like get
on you know lawi or serpenta to come on
and talk about China you go to a Chinese
City and you're going to go to pizza and
you're goingon to have a slice of pizza
like these things exist there there's
competing interest and power at play and
there's no Saints there's no Saints and
there's no saviors I get the CH I've
been to Shanghai it was uh did you have
the hot did you stuff get the stuffed
crust with the hot dog in it no see
that's what I'm talking about you go to
China and this is what concerns me you
go to piz I think it's pizza and they
will stuff make a make they will stuff
your cross with anything including hotg
I get the vibe that they're way more
more Allied and aligned with the United
States than like the the Iranians like
the Chinese are severely oligarchic
businessmen they don't want conflict or
War destruction they want to improve
improve improve and they're willing they
want to buy us out if anything cor the
you are correct the Chinese try to cut
deals with American politicians to gain
power they want to buy land they want to
use soft power to expand whereas Iran
very different and I'm using Iran as an
example but the people that have been
heavily radicalized in the Middle East
from all these bombings and things the
people that have been heavily
radicalized in the Middle East or
radicalized for multiple different
reasons the Chinese like like Tim said
it's all soft power but they still want
to be able to influence and they want to
be you know they're using soft power but
it is to have the United States have
policies that benefit China whether they
be indirectly or directly benefiting
China you know but um but China I mean
CH the really scary thing about Taiwan
so you mentioned sustaining a war right
off China's Coast if you look at the
think tanks have been putting out these
war games and about what a battle would
be like the first battle over Taiwan
like the first few weeks and they never
consider nuclear escalation so this is
the really scary part about China is
that our Pentagon our military leaders
you hear them say they're openly
planning for a direct war with China
they're saying they're trying to deter
War but if it happens they're going to
take them head on they have nukes but
anyway with the war games they again
they don't take into account nuclear
escalation but besides that in the first
few weeks a naval battle over Taiwan
thousands and thousands of American
sailors will be killed Scott Horton
recently just interviewed Lyall gold
Goldstein he worked at the naval war
college for 20 years he speaks Chinese
he's an expert on this he was saying he
thinks tens of thousands American
American Sailors would be killed in the
first few weeks well there there was a
we talked about this I think the other
day that that China does a war game and
in every single scenario a US carrier
gets sunk immed boat on Wares it's
really the same result we got we got we
got to do like a like a war game like a
D and D style war game that'd be fun
that' be Co oh we talked about doing
this we should do two we should do World
War III and and Civil War and do like a
2hour long D and session style thing
yeah there was that does sound fun these
boats and we should bring uh you and
Scott and you guys can be like no guys
get along man no you know you're going
to role plays the neocons okay yeah that
sounds fun I think you know them well
enough and you're gonna be like War like
Scott's gonna be like I'm John Bolton
there's like a World War III RPG like
2020 or something 2030 I don't know they
had it I used to play it in the '90s or
we had the book but the see boats boats
are like so vulnerable to Hypersonic
missiles now especially close boats that
are close to the Chinese land like
they're sitting targets and that's what
China's been preparing for is a war
right there someone just sent someone
just sent me a a um an email or tweeted
tweeted at me there's an
injunction the state of Texas got an
injunction on the federal government for
what they were doing uh it says the date
on it is one second uh filed 1027 23 so
that this this they said was from last
week it's possible that this video is
from before the yeah yeah yeah this is
probably what caused the injunction caus
them to get the to to seek the
injunction so to the state of Texas the
state of Texas got an injunction on the
federal government to get them to
stop basically knocking down the borders
so that way illegal immigrants can come
into the country maybe not treason but
they're definitely attacking State
Authority by going into Texas they're
aing and abetting people who who are not
citizens who are committing crimes
against our nation yeah cuz technically
the feds are supposed to to take care of
the border right like not the state of
Texas because it's an international
border so the federal government has
jurisdiction and they're totally
advocating their their author not only
ad what do you say advocating it but
also violating it well yeah they're not
doing their job as and they're making it
worse too it's not that they're just not
there it's that they're in there cutting
the Barb wires and letting people in
it's crazy my apologies I pulled up the
US national debt Clock a little while
ago if you haven't been to
usdebtclock.org pull it up in a
different tab we're printing $100,000
every three seconds of debt $100,000
every three seconds it's probably be a
million dollars every 30 seconds million
a minute probably going to be a
quintilian dollars in our lifetime I
love how Thomas Massie wears the pin the
it actively calculates the gave one to
Ron Paul it made me very happy I love
that guy Thomas Massie people people
don't understand what this means because
they're like what does that mean I I
don't know anything about that like I
have my money it means that right now
you want to buy a house you're not going
to be able to it means that your milk
that you buy today is going to cost
twice as much tomorrow that's if nothing
changes if we're on this stay on this
track forever we can alter our our gross
domestic production capacity by pivoting
to hydrogen fuel I actually talked with
James T today wow look at this current
okay so the current US uh money supply
is 20.6 trillion US Treasury dollars is
1.5 trillion and the currency and credit
derivatives is 634 trillion wait no no
no is that yeah trillion dollars
damn 600 trillion uh yeah trillion well
when you hear numbers like that it's
just like what it you know it's like
what does that even mean the only the
only time that anyone has ever used
those numbers outside of the national
debt is in like physics when you're
talking about the numbers of like
particles in the universe you know it's
like it it takes that kind of like that
something that massive otherwise these
numbers are completely and totally
impractical the human mind can't even
comprehend it and it's the rate of
change that's also where it becomes
highly impr holy you guys ready for this
yeah the US federal debt to GDP ratio
was
124.401
I wasn't alive we all know about the
Jimmy Carter era and John Lennon John
lennin died in December of 1980 my
mother you say it wasn't 1980 the the uh
34.7 oh okay and that this is this is I
believe 80 was Carter right yeah M well
or was that that when he was he was
getting out yeah Reagan was elected in
in 80 or 79 and then was put in office
in the 80 in 80 or something like that
or it's 80 81 I think maybe yeah and you
know I can't verify that this website's
actually legit either I never have been
able to verify the debt this all
public data yeah yeah and then I
remember it was a big deal because one
day it put like Jesus Christ as Lord on
the on the front page and you had to
like exit out to see and people people
were like wow like conservatives were
all like whoa holy crap cuz this is like
a big website mhm something like that
happened it was recently I think look at
this the interest on the debt 676
billion that's not even that much is
that a lot of money I thought it was
going to be more than that the interest
on the debt is going
up that's I've always considered no I
think this is specifically for um the
interest of the debt is for Medicare
Social Security and
defense wow but the issue is that's
that's not the debt that's the interest
on top it's going up we we're not paying
that down as Ian and brings us up if the
interest keeps going up you can't pay
back more interest by taking another
loan to pay back you get more interest
yep we need to increase the value of our
dollar is what we need to do worldwide
gold standard yeah or I I'm big into
hydrogen fuel and because if we can
start producing things that are val or
and graphine because if we can start
producing things that we can sell around
the world graphine is like $60,000 a ton
and they are just churning it out at
Rice University right now or you know
what's what is that stuff that like blue
crab blood or whatever you know what I'm
talking about blue crude no is that what
they call it it's horseshoe crab blood
like the most expensive material in the
world or something I'm from I'm from
Long Long Island and we just had the
every once in a while some random like
horseshoe crab genocide would happen or
something and they just be all over the
beach and I always hear that it's worth
they're it's like worth money they blood
and I'm like man I should have been
collecting their blood when I was a kid
those are like the blue blue horseshoe
cribs or whatever and they like hook
them all up to tubes and extract blood
slowly and it's like I don't know what
the deal is but I've I've seen that
antibacterial it's in the medical
industry but we need like when you talk
about a dollar like I'm a Libertarian so
you always we're always talking about
the gold standard but you know we could
have a different commodity based dollar
there are different things that can back
the dollar hey we can go to 2027 we can
go to the Future based on all these
projections where we'll be I'll give it
to me oh my God I love this this is four
years from now four years from now the
average family is going to have $100,000
in their savings that is really bad that
is not good it says today that the
average family has 11,000 yep and it
says it's going to be 10x in 4 years and
if the uh the debt to GDP ratio goes
from 124 124% to 15% that means the
buying the just a general correlation is
not perfect but that 10x increase in how
much money you have correlates with like
a 12 12 uh times decrease in your buying
power spend your dollars get rid of them
buy even like I know that like there's
there's people that that sounds like
Financial advice Phil oh yeah well I'm
not giving you any Financial advice I
like to spend dollar and get things that
are valuable I I know that that you know
whether it be Bitcoin or gold or silver
or ammo or whatever land is great you
know bu I think that you know I'm going
to be buying things that are going to
retain value or go up in value I'm
probably not going to be hanging on to
very much cash I like to invest in
machines that I can use to increase my
income my profitability things like that
a really good camera really good
microphone if you use it I mean look I'm
not assets per citizen per citizen 1.2
million I ain't telling you what to do
but Electronics don't hold their value
yeah but it's you use it in the short
term to increase productivity I've
turned into like a civil war nerd since
I moved to Virginia cuz there's like a
million battlefields where I live and
there's signs everywhere you notice cool
like you you you'll go to a dock for
like to launch a fishing boat and
there's like a sign be like this is
where this General killed this General I
Liv near Petersburg and it was like
almost a years long Siege around the
city so there's battles everywhere but
it's got me kind of collecting like old
antiques and that's actually a really
good investment is like really old
antiques they just uh like a like a
Charizard go up in value I was thinking
that I used to have so many the crazy
thing is I think I had probably like
five first edition Charizards when I was
a kid and they were like worth a little
bit I don't even know what happened to
them they're all gone but now they're
worth like 10 to $20,000 you checked
your beanie babies ever get I have not
an ed I lost all my old magic cards that
was brutal one day on a train I I was
we're on a train and I was like I fell
asleep and then they're like oh we're at
our stop get up and I get up and jump
off the train and I go I turn back and
the door closes and I'm like all my
card's gone and that was that's probably
100 Grand worth of magic cards gone yeah
they really worth that much now yeah but
but because the cards back then were not
that not that valuable but we're talking
25 24 years now they're all extremely
rare and out of print and more valuable
I wonder what Alpha Black Lotus is what
$1.2 million for an alpha black lotus
was it like rated 10 yeah. yeah the most
valuable Magic
card 1.2 million that thing was like
6600 yeah you're probably looking like a
special auction because a rated eight is
140 Grand okay that's
crazy wow $1 million for a freaking
piece of cardboard it was 700 when I was
a kid and we were like wow $700 that's
crazy man wow who knows it's going to be
worth money you know what I'm saying
that's the thing do you remember the
Beanie Babies everybody was like oh
these are going to be worth something
one day but I don't think they ever were
nope that was that was a tulip thing
that was a Dutch tulip Fiasco but Phil I
think a cool thing for you to like spend
money on and collect you could get
antique like firearms from like the
1800s yeah and they look awesome and you
can mount them on your wall and they
just grow in value oh wow that's an
actual Union Civil War rifled musket
yeah that's awesome I have a breach
loader uh I forget the name of it what I
need breach loader loading rifle from
the Civil Warrior I have a pinfire
revolver uh which is kind of a rare type
um pinfire like it had a little pin that
stuck out of it and the hammer would hit
the pin and that's what would fire the
shell oh wow yeah they didn't really
they weren't around for long but uh
Calvary officers had them on the Union
and Confederate side so it's pretty cool
it's like I got I bought it for like 800
bucks a few years ago and it's just they
used you know the longer you hold on to
it the more of I think I think the
revolvers back then were uh the more
ubiquitous was the percussion cap and
that's so like like little metal primer
goes in the back of you know each
chamber and then it hits the primer
which ignites the the musk ball or
whatever whatever they were using the
bullet at the time we we've actually got
some actual Civil War bullets because uh
we have a civil war bayonet somewhere oh
yeah yeah we found it on the property
yeah and it's all rusted and you know
and we're just like oh whatever they're
all over the place super cool I've been
metal detected on my property cuz
there's a battle my my I'm I'm wondering
what relics people will find from the
next civil war so they're going to find
you know iPhone iPhone 15 and uh my uh
my buddy back in in New Hampshire he he
does a lot of metal detecting and he's
trying to get into uh off liit places
because you know New England's been
around a long time so people have done a
lot of hunting and stuff so he's trying
to find places where he's not allowed
that he can sneak into but I won't blow
him up I'm kind of like yeah if we sit
around and and just kind of complain for
the next 6 months it could be the end of
the the world but if we really Pioneer
new tech like hydrogen Tech and really
push it really push it we could probably
come out of this on top it depends so if
what we're facing right now is actually
a legitimate threat of World War III the
population decrease from war and from
the fact that people don't have kids
means what you're hoping for is less
likely to occur Tech technological
expansion typically requires population
expansion like the the how many people
does it take to make one monitor screen
it's it's probably like 500 different
Specialties to make one computer monitor
but because of the international economy
and how everything operates someone gets
Cobalt here and someone gets you know
quartz here and someone mines the the
oil or drills for the oil over here and
then they all go on these different
marketplaces I think a really good
example is probably just like pod Thai
or something some like ridiculous dish
that has a spice from Asia and a a
vegetable from Mexico and you're like
this this unnatural demonic food would
never exist were it not for our big oil
tankers you know our big cargo ships
around the oceans to bring all these
ingredients together true if the
population declines too much you lose
Specialties and then you're going to
have a guy's going to be like look man
we need someone who can extract hydrogen
but we don't have that anymore so I can
work on that but then we don't have a
guy who handles the Plastics we don't
have a guy who handles the the the the
electronics Ian you're worried about
like the world World War III bringing
the world to an end or is there
something else you're worried about
is it World War that's got you nervous
yeah yeah because you know for what I do
I basically read the new you know all
day every day I sort through like
hundreds of news articles read about
this uh you know war in Ukraine tensions
with China and all that and I don't like
to be hyperbolic in my show and stuff
but I always say like if we wake up
tomorrow and Russia bombed a NATO base
in Poland and we're actually at war with
Russia or if a chinese ship and a
American ship shot at each other in the
South China Sea and then a bunch of it
escalated and all of a sudden we're at
war with China you know don't be
surprised we shouldn't be surprised
because at this the state of the world
that we're in right now what they're
just pushing everybody all over the
planet it's really uh you know it is
very scary and again I don't try to be
over hyperbolic but what they're doing
they're leading us down a path of global
war the likes of which you know we've
never seen especially with new
technology and I I I always I always
want to stress too because especially
when we had uh you know I shout out
again culture War podcast you / timcast
uh Steven Marsh and I were talking
before the show started cuz he was I
showed him the Civil War rifle and he
was like what was the first the first
battle and I was like uh Bull Run
manessis and he was like right right and
they didn't even think it wasn't even a
battle it was like a street fight like
nobody knew what was going on and I'm
like yes what we considered to be the
first battle I mean obviously Fort
Sumter is a start of it but that wasn't
even a battle it was like uh only one
guy died and it was an accident I don't
think anybody died one guy it was
accident it was one death it was
accidental it was like uh I can't
remember exactly what happened but but
uh then you had the B the First Battle
of Bull Run and no one thought the fight
was actually going to happen and at the
time when it did happen nobody called it
the Civil War nobody called it the war
in the states it was not a war at all
now we look back and say both sides
thought it would be over so quick so
it's
possible that in a 100 years they say
World War III started uh December of
2022 yeah it's possible they say it
started with the with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine the US I think of it
as 911 personally
the US was just stomping on everyone's
neck for the first 18 years of it yeah
but bro the US has been doing that for a
lot longer than but 911 changed like
lockdown police state crap you know
Patriot Act people were getting you take
your shoes off at the airport kind of
crap looking over your shoulder afraid
of Muslims like all this dumb I'll tell
you so just an an anecdote about when I
went to China I remember getting in or I
was getting on the plane to fly I forget
where we were flying next but I was all
nervous going through their security I
was like I'm going to have to take my
shoes off it's China they're going to
really go crazy and Pat me down and I
started like taking my belt off and they
were just like come on come on through
and they just like hit me with the wand
and I was like oh wow and then when we
got back into the US my wife bought like
some hand cream in Australia and they
put it in like a special bag and they
were like you can't you know they like
shook her down and like ripped apart all
her stuff and said she couldn't bring it
in or if she wanted to she had to like
mail it to it was crazy I'm like this is
just the the remnants of of 9/11 of what
they did to us after that it hasn't gone
away I mean I don't know if it's the
remnants of 911 there the thing that
we're experiencing is not actually about
stopping terrorism it's the it's the
fact that once you start a government
program they never go away it's the
infrastructure for the TSA that was
designed for you know designed initially
to stop terrorism never stopped a thing
it's an addiction yeah so what happens
is the US government says we're going to
spend $100 million on War they invest in
all these companies the companies build
up a big employee base they hire a bunch
of people next year comes around and
that company goes to Congress and says
are you are you going to give us that
same deal again go well I don't think we
need it there's no war and they go
listen we employ 500 people in your
district and if we don't have this
contract we're firing them and we're
going to tell them it's because of you
no no no no no no no no no you got my
vote you got my vote yeah yep so what we
got to do is make hit
music I'm talking like Marvin Gay I've
been really we need to make babies and
we need to inspire people to have sex
and have children and that's music
that's like because if we have kids it's
not enough you need to you need to mass
produce love and we need to make
hydrogen fuel and graphine to get out of
this steel hell hole that we're in and
start making lightweight super conductor
conductors locally really fast and
cheaply I I you
know I got to stop right here Ian is
completely correct on graphine because
steel was such a large component of our
industry of our jobs of our economy uh
the Steelers Pittsburgh how much steel
is still being made in the US I do not
believe very much but uh either way if
we had an industrial revolution on par
with uh uh you know what it was in the
past and we bring back a bunch of jobs
you could have manufacturing plants pop
up all over the place it could
Revitalize uh dying towns it could
create new cities and it's it's going to
have to be you know we we we we we often
do joke about caffine and Ian fervor but
the reality
is it is a bold move to reconfigure an
economy towards building a material that
can be used to expand and create a bunch
of new products uh my favorite example A
lot of the stuff we use plastics for
instance and I think paper towels a
bunch of stuff were invented uh for
space so like a lot of the things we use
are invented by yeah the space race and
then it's like oh this is convenient
people might want to use it we can't
just sit here and be like let's just
keep doing the same thing we've always
done we need to be like guys we should
be we're doing we have the chips act
we're we're making silicon chips in in
Arizona now or we're starting to that's
great that's a great idea we should have
a some in some way it's going to require
I I believe most of the private sector
it's which mean which means a cultural
shift where we get someone who goes I
want to bring together a bunch of
financial institutions and invest
hundred billion in manufacturing plants
for graphine we're going to employ five
million people in the United States and
we're going to be exporting a a a a
building material and superconductor
which is going to be in in major demand
around the world that will massively
increase uh uh benefit the US economy
yeah the Department of Defense is
working with uh scientists at Rice
University to pump this stuff out
graphine I think for every $4.50 of
graphine you get a kilogram of hydrogen
fuel and so they're actually getting
they're making money to produce before
it was like it cost a dollar it cost $3
to make a kilogram of hydrogen now
you're getting $4.50 to produce a
kilogram of hydrogen it's right in front
of us so I interviewed James T today the
leading chemist one of the leading
chemists on Earth that's producing this
stuff it's an hour of us talking about
it he gets really we we scratch the
surface and do highly highly uh
influential explanations go to my
YouTube channel and check it out it's
the first video you'll see it's James T
this guy's phenomenal we're right on the
precipice man now we just got to hold it
together and inspire people I'm I'm kind
of at a loss what it is that you think
graphine is going to do you can put it
in um cement in in there's a lot of
things and you watch the video for if
you want to hear more what does steel do
well steel is used for all kinds of
stuff it reinforces concrete and
graphine does that you can put it in
concrete it makes it lighter and more
three times more durable and it's uh so
we we so we we use lithiumion batteries
for our phones they're actually starting
to create uh uh graphine polymer uh lith
or lithium graphine batteries uh
graphine layer in the battery creates a
a um what's the word lce a unilateral
charge okay so it charges from every
Point all at once which charges the
battery much more quickly so graphing it
could conducts electricity it's a superc
conductor okay right so uh so whereas a
cell phone would take 1550 minutes to
charge in the past it'll now take five
we now have the we actually bought a
bunch of these a year ago portable
batteries when you plug your phone in
it'll charge your phone from zero to
full in 10 minutes be uh uh or I'm sorry
I'm sorry it it can hold a full cell
phone charge after only 10 or so minutes
your phone whether or not you have the
graphine Polymer batteries or or or or
the gra what is it graphine lithium I I
don't I for what it's called but they're
they're they're putting them in
batteries they think that this
technology in electric car batter
batteries means you'll pull your car up
to the pump at the gas station plug in
the supercharger and you'll literally
watch the charge go up like a gas tank
wow they used to they were like how do
we make this stuff graphing for the last
20 years how do we make it chemical
vapor deposition they're trying to
deposit carbon dioxide onto copper and
get it and you you get these strips they
figured out what's called Flash Jewel
graphine production you you hit it with
electrical current any Carbon on Earth
you can get all these different Plastics
they used to have to recycle them and PE
pull them apart because different
Plastics recycle differently any carbon
all the plastic together Fe human feces
plants matter any carbon and you hit it
with electricity and you turn it into
graphine and then this guy I'm actually
going to be uh uh interviewing the
inventor Dewey long so so but let's
bring it back to the the the debt this
country my point is I will I will go
along with Ian on graphine for one
reason we need a manufacturing base we
need the American people working on raw
materials that we can use to build
infrastructure steel for a long time not
just steel there's a lot of stuff we did
in the United States we should drill
baby drill we should invade Canada I'm
I'm sorry well we should invade I'm at
Alaska but Canada yes too I'm I mean I'm
only half kidding but no we should
invade and occupy Alaska we should not
waste our here's what I think when we go
and blow up people overseas what we are
doing is we are creating a global
economy as Hollow as a Fiat dollar we we
we we provide you nothing other than
don't screw with us and these other
countries say your offers are Hollow we
only need protection from you if the US
said okay we are going to bolster our
manufacturing develop new technologies
create a very strong robust middle class
that works in development of new
technology and and new infrastructure
and new ra raw materials and meta
materials we occupy Alaska using our own
land to se uh Rare Earth minerals for
instance stop doing dealings with China
would then become that shining City on
the hill and other other nations would
say we got to be like them we got to do
business with them yeah and if we're not
don't have a global Empire you know we
should be able to do those things
without having this Empire you mentioned
the chips act so the problem with the
chips Act is that it's basically
corporate subsidies $50 billion which is
adding to the debt the you know I think
the answer isn't subsidizing this
industry um which is something you know
China does I think we should uh you know
resort to more capitalism and deregulate
and you know give people tax incentives
and to start factories and you know
they're actually getting a lot of the
Taiwanese companies to build Factory the
things that you're going to have to do
to get to get the to get people to start
businesses like that is I don't know I
don't know the first thing about making
chips or anything but I mean the between
unions minimum wages and the the amount
of things that you have to deregulate
and pull back on it's just astronomical
so I whereas understand and agree with
your your your point I don't think that
it's that bad to have the government try
to do things to tax breaks or whatever
to incentivize companies to start it but
they're giving them billions of dollars
check out uh you know 50 billion that's
a lot of money I'd rather them give it
to to a company in the US then give it
to Israel to drop bombs they're giving
it to a lot a lot of it's going to
Taiwanese companies to bring them here
which I'm not sure the you know the
percentages but I know some of it at
because the reason the big reason why we
have you know companies that are doing
things over season stuff is because of
labor laws and because of regulations
here so if you environmental regulations
yeah the if you can p roll those back
then you could get then there's an
incentive for companies to start but as
long as the federal government has the
the type of legislation that or
regulation that that disincentivizes
companies from starting I mean it's got
to start it somehow and I I want I want
to correct you one thing not really
correct but I want to counter um I want
a strong robust American Empire that is
achieved by being really cool producing
great products being a great trade
partner not interfering other countries
business and politics but being so good
at everything we do that they want to
learn from us we want we want other
countries to say let us know what you
need that new thing you guys are working
on your econom is really great we all
love America we want to be like America
your movies are awesome we want to win
through cultural means yes not bombing
children yeah culture and science those
are my two favorites we the US Empire
uses force in a lot of different ways
you know if countries like elect the
government that the US doesn't like they
start putting economic sanctions on them
you know purposely to destroy their
economy yes yes but let's be fair the US
also removes that government by force
and then puts in a sock puppet
government sometimes sometimes but other
times they just sanction the hell out of
them yeah and you know that's that's
part of the reason why you know the US
on the global stage right now if you're
like a developing country and you see
the way the US operates especially now
all for the past year and a half you had
blink in Biden talking about you know
lecturing Russia on the war in Ukraine
talking about this rules-based order and
now we see them fully backing Israel as
they're just blowing up kids and
everybody can see it for themselves it's
like the hypocrisy is is very obvious to
other countries but the the the funny
thing about Russia and Ukraine is Russia
is having a territorial territorial
dispute with a neighboring country MH
the United States flew to the other side
of the planet to invade Iraq and
Afghanistan it's true and why was Iraq
invaded well I guess it was wmds but
9/11 was kind of the pretext why was
Afghanistan invaded well because the
Taliban were were harboring Osama Bin
Laden so we we got to go and build a
nation there and then Russia invades a
neighboring country over a border
dispute and we're like whoa whoa hey
there wait a minute Kisa rice like a few
days after sorry if I got a little
worked up there Ian you looked a little
startled I'm so into this cona rice a
few days after Russia invaded was on TV
and was like I forget exactly what she
said but condalisa rice of the George W
Bush Administration said a country
cannot invade another Sovereign Nation
or something like that and did you see
do you remember George W Bush's little
uh Freudian slip or whatever it was he
was giving a speech and he was like one
man's decision to invade uh Iraq uh uh I
mean Ukraine and then he kind of lefted
and he was like yeah Iraq too that was a
moment man I watched that video like a
hundred times CU country is full of
definitely somewhere in his brain but
the founding fathers I think if they saw
what was going on they'd be like they'd
be stacking bodies they'd be like why
your businessman in politics it's like
your grandfather being like son I gifted
you this really nice car and you toted
it you know what I mean yeah no the
found I want to stress this point too
the founding fathers notoriously just
petitioned over and over again and it I
I I think it's fair to say it was not
the Americans who started the
Revolutionary War it was the British
imposing tyranny like if we go straight
to lik and conquered they said hand over
your guns or else the Americans the
founding fathers were like I'm going to
write a strongly worded letter to the
king and the King's like screw off I'll
write another letter to the king and it
was a year and a month after uh uh
Lexington Lexington and Conquer they
signed the Declaration of Independence
so it's not like the Americans were like
it's time to stack bodies they were like
Please Please We're just trying to have
some representation here fair enough but
you know Washington did cross the
Delaware and kill everybody in their
sleep so true too but but in the war my
point is was later we America may be
Rebels but when we started we were not
the dudes who decided to go and kill
other people we were the dudes who who
honorably and reasonably said listen
what you're doing is not working and we
are telling you now this has to change
and if you don't listen to us the change
will come either way and then it was the
crown that was like we're going to come
and put you down and then we said we
didn't start it you did they came to
they came to Le and Concord and they
said we are going to come at you it was
not Americans who went to England to to
to fight it was the crown sending
regulars to to the colonies saying we
are going to impose our will from
overseas on you and brought the guns and
then demanded of of the Americans I
think that the the the the the founders
of this country were calm rational
reasonable people who understood war was
bad they did not want foreign
entanglements I love reading about the
the barber Wars and Thomas Jefferson and
like he's like we don't want to be
involved in any of this stuff why are
you attacking in us what are the barber
Wars this is cool Pirates North Africa
and Jefferson and other founding fathers
Adams they're all basically just saying
like look man we're just selling stuff
we have no problem with any of you why
don't you leave us alone and they're
like screw you we do what we want they
said to the it was they said to the to
the in England they said to the the
United States Representative they said
the Quran gives us the the approval and
authorization to kill you and take your
stuff because you are infidels and so
Thomas Jefferson created the United
States Marine Corps and that was the the
response was send in the Marines so the
Marines have been fighting for the
country for as long as there has been a
country this is the barber War series of
two wars fought by the United States
Sweden and the king of Sicily against
the barbery states Tunis alers and
Tripoli yeah and you made a point the uh
I oh sorry the the the United States
Marine Corps the Marine Corps hymn
there's the line that says uh to the
shores of Tripoli that's what it's
referencing from the halls of monuma to
the Shor of trip trip the Marine Corps
fought for the United States that's a
good song all right I like it I remember
you made the point before we started
recording that like you favor you know
the us could have a strong Navy and kind
of police the waters a bit and work with
their trading partners to counter piracy
and I think that is a completely
legitimate uh you know foreign policy to
have just to have a navy and fight
piracy with your trading partners but
we're just so far from that we're in you
know meddling in every country around
world you know we're not anything close
to that a lot of people like to point to
the barbery wars as an example of how
all the founding fathers actually were
not you know non-interventionists but
they were responding to their property
you know being attacked so it's
completely different protecting
Americans yeah um yeah and so this is
completely different analogy from what
you were talking about about how the
British brought the war here my my point
was the founding father's attitude was
like hey let's just mind our own
business we're going to do our thing
here you leave us alone and now the
mentality of the United States is we
offer nothing but we take M yeah so what
I what I imagine the United States is
doing with with the current Empire it's
it's like a a piece of bubble gum it's
being blown up and blown up and blown up
but we know what happens eventually it
gets thinner and thinner and thinner and
then it pops there is nothing within
this bubble it is hollow the United
States cannot exist by simply going out
with guns and saying we get to do this
we can invade Iraq and Afghanistan but
Russia better not invade anybody else to
be fair Russia shouldn't invade Ukraine
but the US has no leg to no moral leg to
stand on what the US should do the US
should have some type of whatever you
want to call it Empire in the sense that
we are so good our laws are just our
people are fat and happy I mean that
figuratively our economy is great and
it's done through production it's done
through trade it's done through
technological development and then what
happens nobody's people people will be
jealous because we're rich that always
happens but we're not blowing up kids
we're not aoral crack pots our money
isn't being siphoned away from us our
economy is expanding our families are
happy our kids are happy our roads are
taken care of our infrastructure is
taken care of and other countries are
like we need to be like them look how
well they're doing you want to spread
democracy or whatever it is you call it
that's how you do it you show up in a
country with guns and then kill the
elderly and then try to raise a new
generation and you get Afghanistan
doesn't
work I love it I think that the United
States China and Russia have a duty to
protect the planet especially the Arctic
it's so important we we're right on the
brink one thing back to the British like
bringing the war to America you know
when we talk about Ukraine I mean for so
long Putin and the Russians were telling
you know the US like you know stop doing
what you're doing stop it and you know
in the weeks and months leading up to
the invasion you know almost a year
before they were you know massing troops
and they they uh submitted these
security proposals they wanted NATO to
be rolled back they wanted a guarantee
that Ukraine would never join NATO and
the US just said no basically to their
main demand of Ukraine joining NATO a
state department official admitted this
in an interview shortly after the
Russian invasion and so you know and I'm
not you know justifying Russia's
Invasion but it is very clear how the US
and the West provoke this thing and you
know that's the thing that's on Russia's
border we're you know we can't even we
try to put our self in the other
person's shoes could you imagine if
Russia was funding a war in Canada you
know like there was a civil war there
and then we intervened and Russia
started sending them missiles and
intelligence there was just a report in
the Washington Post that said the CIA in
2015 started building up Ukraine's
intelligence Services the sbu and the g
which is their their Military
Intelligence to the tune of tens of
millions of dollars and uh they were
basically saying that because of that
support Ukraine's able to kill people
inside Russia they pointed to the car
bombing of Daria dugina do you guys know
who she is of course the daughter of
Alexander Dugan that the Ukrainian did
they basically pointed to that saying
they were a they're able to do this the
CIA and the statue that exploded do we
know what that was about you remember
that there was a internet personality in
Russia someone brought in a small bus
head St
ped yeah that's that was them too that
that that report said it was them and
you know it closed with a very ominous
quote from like a former CIA official
basically saying like what have we
created here what if they start killing
people in third countries you know what
if you know like the blowback from this
Ukraine war could be very serious it's
going to be like Afghanistan it is it is
going to be uh uh like like the
mujahedin it is it is Ukraine is now uh
uh what was it the Republicans pass a
funding bill for Israel but not Ukraine
they're saying it's going to be dead in
the Senate Joe Biden here let let me
pull the story up post millennial Biden
admin announces additional $425 million
military package to Ukraine so we have
weaponized and armed Ukraine but Ukraine
is losing the appetite for funding this
is on the decline and we've got an
election coming up what do you think
happens to
the extreme I'm not saying extremist I'm
saying like very fervent national uh
militia groups in Ukraine who are funded
and trained by US forces when the US
pulls out and says you're on your own MH
you talk about the fear of bombings in
third countries other non you know
outside of Russia and stuff 100% And
then what happens give it 20 years and
you've got trained armed groups in
Ukraine who hate the United States for
some reason or another and you get
Al-Qaeda all over again yeah in some
form or another there's you know cuz you
you hear the Russians talk about the
Nazis in Ukraine but there is a real
Neo-Nazi element in Ukraine um you know
it's not huge but it is very influential
and there are certain groups so there
was like these raids going on in Russia
that were done by this group called The
Russian volunteer Corps they were
Russians Russian people that were
fighting you know went over to Ukraine
in 2014 to fight for them and they're
like openly Neo-Nazi wow and they had
American armored vehicles so you had a
group of neo-nazis basically invading
Russia and I think this was belgrad they
they tried this a few times they didn't
get much done but you have a group a
band of Nazis invading Russia with
American weapons like again fathom try
to put
yourself you know we can't even imagine
something like that happening to the the
Russians are actually uh probably just
defly sensitive to
Nazis I think that it's it's probably
fair I mean the Optics of it of Germany
sending Ukraine uh leopard tanks with
the iron cross on them like what makes
how could this happen what makes them
Nazis is it like racial superiority
mindset or something yeah um you know
I'm not I don't Focus too much on the
Nazi element but there is like the aoff
Battalion that was basically a Neo-Nazi
militia uh during the 2014 donbass War
and the and the coup and everything that
joined uh the Ukrainian forces and
there's also you know the history of
Bandera and the Ukrainian nationalists
during the World War I that worked with
the Nazis and there are people that wear
you know Nazi
iconography uh on their uniforms and
stuff and it is pretty prevalent like
you'll you'll notice it um in pictures
of Ukrainian Soldiers with this certain
Nazi icons um so it is definitely an
element of their you know what they call
the far right I kind of hate using the
term far right these days because people
probably call me far right but it is
like there's certainly that element
inside Ukraine I think it's worth
breaking apart what Nazism is exactly
Hitler just used that term National
Socialist and he made some psychotic
political movement out of it but he
called it National Socialist but just if
you're a nationalist and you're a
socialist doesn't mean you're a Nazi
like Hitler kind of means you're a Nazi
well so there's not a lot of Light
Between the as much as the Socialists
and Communists don't want to admit this
there's not a lot of light between
Communists and Nazis right they they the
Nazis are Nationalist and they they have
a lot of racism but the and the
Communists tend to not be nationalists
they want to see a global socialism but
they're racist too A lot of the times
and you can see that in in the way that
the the Socialists are are behaving
towards a lot of the the Jewish people
that that you see a lot of the
anti-Semitism that's going on now so
there's not a sign not a lot of
difference there are there are Nuance
differences but the real significant IDE
logical differences are between
liberalism and Socialism or Liber you
liberalism and socialism which Nazism is
a type of socialism because liberalism
is is based on enlightenment principles
right so the the fundamental thing about
liberalism is the individual should be
free to live their life and that the
government is there to maybe have a
social safety net maybe not but there's
different and there's different amounts
of governments that are acceptable but
with socialist ideologies the the
collective comes first so the Nazis
believe that the German people came
first and Communists believe that the
workers come before anyone else but it's
a it's a so it's a a collectivist versus
an individual ideology so there's
there's not a whole the differences
between Nazis and commies is only
Nuance it was basically like Nazis were
traditional and commies were Progressive
yeah but they were all super
authoritarian wanted to lock you up in a
cage and and kill your family exactly
but to get back to this uh the $425
million that they're announcing here so
this is uh money that they do have left
they have they're kind of running out of
money to send over there so Biden in
that $15 billion package that he
requested it includes 61 billion to keep
the the Ukraine war going for another
year they want to do it so they could
get through the 2024 election and again
there was just solu the Ukrainian
commander-in-chief just did an interview
with the economist saying it's a
stalemate there's not going to be a
breakthrough but that doesn't matter to
Biden they want to keep this thing going
they want people to be you know there's
still there's been fighting territory
hasn't changed hands much but a lot of
people are dying and that's what they
want to continue funding um so it's
really just sick stuff I mean I think
this the dying part is is just uh I I
don't think that it's what they're after
I think the money and the the and stuff
is what they're after and then the
people dying that's happens they don't
care they just slimy well if you
actually see how some Senators kind of
pitch this now I know this is uh I know
Mitt Romney was saying this recently you
know their argument for continuing this
war going is oh we're getting our
money's worth you know I got an idea mhm
uh what What's the total number of uh
members of Congress 435 435 all right
it's a little bit more than the
425 but uh here's a deal we the American
people will give each member of Congress
$1 million to not fund war and so you
have the it's it's it's it's a good and
a bad we got to negotiate here we are
going to have to spend that money which
adds to the deficit devalues your
currency but at least it stays as
currency United States for trade and we
aren't blowing up people or funding war
in other countries yeah it sounds like a
win so members of Congress if you vote
against this I say we give you all a
million dollar tax free tax free
yeah pay pay members of Congress a
million dollars but only hey wait here's
an idea any year with no active War
members of Congress receive a million
dollar
bonus yeah that sounds great I'm in yeah
and and and and Sate
included yeah they're never going to get
it
but no because you you got M Congress
being like million dollar bonus huh but
Ron's going to pay me two million after
I get out of Congress and go take that
job and Lobby for him well that's
another thing now like the corruption is
so obvious like Lloyd Austin Biden's
defense secretary he came straight off
the board of race
and he they he started funding this war
in Ukraine that made all these weapons
Ron weapons in very high demand weapons
that they stopped making stock started
going up yeah this you know the Stinger
missiles the anti-aircraft missiles that
they gave to the mujah hadin in
Afghanistan those were basically
obsolete you know I think they were
selling some to Taiwan uh they but they
stopped making them a while ago and now
they're in hot demand they're calling in
like 70-year-old rathon Engineers to
start making them but this but but it is
you know the point I made about industry
so you you have a you have a
manufacturer who makes um he makes
bullets and let's say he makes a th000
bullets per week mhm the government
comes comes to them and says we really
like the quality of your ammo can you
produce for us an additional thousand
and the guy goes if I'm going to do that
I got to hire like five more people for
like Logistics and all this and they say
well we can pay you a premium we'll pay
you x amount and the guy goes wow I'm
going to I'm it's it's 2.2 times my
revenue for for uh only two times the
ammo like I got a good premium on this
deal next month he says I've got these
employees working here are you going to
rent my contract and they say no and he
goes then what do I do with these
employees so the problem is the war
machine becomes an addiction where it's
not just about the kind of bribery of
I'm going to tell your constituents you
did this it's that okay look if we lay
off 100,000 people econom is going to
get hit by this you got to keep building
these things just to keep the economy
going because these jobs will be lost
otherwise that's how they make the
argument that's what blink blink's been
saying that recently oh it's good for
American jobs to spend all this money on
Wars I loved it when Trump said it he
said it with the sa exactly he's like
we're going to sell them a bunch of
weapons it's great for the economy and
it's like oh wow I hear that they s the
government contracts are longterm
they'll do like I don't know how many
year turn contracts but they don't do
like onee contract if you get a
government contract apparently it's very
lucrative for your company you're set I
remember a long time ago there's a story
where uh you don't even have to do a
good job the the the mil one of the
Armed for like the army or whatever said
we we are we are we do not need any more
tanks and then Congress says Nope and
then pass legislation to build more
saying we don't care what you think slow
targets wonderful Hypersonic missiles
and the reason that that they do that is
because or the reason they can do that
is because they they break up the
production of them throughout multiple
uh congressional districts so you'll
have the pieces that go into tanks made
throughout the whole country so no one
person can say we're going to stop this
because everybody's like well if we stop
making the tanks there's going to be job
loss Nationwide or in these 50
congressional districts and the Congress
people are like no you're not going to
do anything that's going to affect our
job market so the incentive is not just
from the government it's or it's not
just the government wants these things
it's the way that the government has set
up intentionally set up the production
of these of weapons and stuff like that
it's it's throughout the whole economy
and so youve got you've got the
incentive for multiple people in
Congress to say no to vote against it if
you want to St you want to add anything
to that before you jump I was just going
to say I remember Matt Gates voted for
you know he's been very good on the wars
uh some wars in the Middle East he
introduced resolutions to leave Syria
and stuff unfortunately he just voted to
give israel4 billion to fund that war
but I remember he voted for the ndaa oh
yeah and and he just said the infamous
oh okay a recent one uh I don't remember
exactly when but I just remember he went
on Twitter and he's like I voted for the
ndaa because real quick National
authorization yeah sorry so it's the
annual basically Pentagon spending bill
that they pass every year and Gates just
said I voted for the ndaa because it
brings jobs to you know the district I
represent in Florida and that's that and
it's like okay at least he's honest
about what he's doing you know this you
know I would hope to see him vote
against it because it's just such a
behemoth but did he vote for this one
what 14 billion package was it just that
or was it part of an Omnibus it was 14.3
billion for military aid for Israel the
way that Johnson the new house speaker
and his people wrote wrote it up was
that it cuts the 14 billion from the
IRS right right right and sends it to
which is such a republican move it's
like oh yeah we're going to make some
cuts and send it to fund a war in Gaza
so well to be fair it is better than
just adding to the debt but it's still
not good I think n daas count as Omnibus
bills because they they have all kinds
of stuff so I I do want to jump to this
very very big story but the first thing
I want to announce is uh uh Mark
Zuckerberg Tes ACL uh he was training
for an MMA fight Dam and I just want to
say shout out sry hear it buddy I hope
you get better ACL tears are no joke
dude you got this I he's he got a
picture of him in in the hospital no I
sincerely mean it not a fan of a lot of
things that Facebook has done but uh man
ACL tear is brutal Elon you should reach
out send your well wishes Elon was
joking with Joe Rogan about how he was
going to dominate Mark in a in an MMA
match and he was fun laughing and
laughing so hopefully Elon you'll yeah
your ACL is like a strong strong
component in your knee and and that this
can end careers for for pro athletes and
stuff so I well Mark has access to the
best medic on Earth I'm excited to watch
his recovery he like really trains right
like Elon Musk probably couldn't take
yeah Elon was like I'm a wallrus if I
lay on him he won't be able to get up
Joe's like that's not how it works dude
he'll get put in a submission get choked
you're done yep yep he'll tap out um
okay we got a big story this is a story
from the Daily Mail about vaccines and
vaccines are on the ballot the first
thing I want to say is ladies and
gentlemen don't take medical advice from
podcasters and talk to your doctor about
what's right for you but this story is
very interesting as per the sentiment
held by people in this country and how
it relates to to RFK Jr versus Trump and
Biden check out this headline according
to the Daily Mail a quarter of Americans
say coid 19 shots are unsafe and that
they know someone who died from one as
2024 wannabes to sandis and RFK Jr take
skepticism on the campaign Trail I think
this number is Highly Questionable that
one in four Americans know someone who
died that is a a strong like we I think
we'd hear in the news about that many
people having died that being said I
want to
clarify if there are 10 people and they
all know Bill and Bill dies and then you
ask these 10 people do you know someone
who died they'll all say yes oh that's a
great Point yes it's it's still just one
people that know them who know Bill
might also say yes you know friend my
friend and they're like oh yeah it's
like oh I know some D yeah my friend's
friend bill you know what I mean so we
don't know exactly what this means also
I didn't get asked so they didn't do a a
holistic it actually does say um despite
several attempts Ian crossin did not
respond to her question I never will
emails Ian I want to stress uh YouTube
calm down uh I am not talking about this
because I care to talk about the
efficacy or issues around vaccines
that's for you guys and your doctors or
whatever I do think it is politically
important that people feel this way
because there's a question of uh we're
talking with Luke rowski about RFK Jr
and Luke was saying there's a good
there's a good possibility that RFK
could take votes from Trump because
Trump was bad on vaccine mandates and
lockdown BS and RFK Jr is good and I say
yeah but the you know the core
ideologies of RFK Jr and Trump are so
different you I think you're going to
find somebody who says I'm willing to
forgive Trump on a lot of things because
he's anti-woke he's challenging these
government contracts no new Wars Etc and
RFK Jr called Columbus Day indigenous
people's day and that's like a red flag
for a lot of people yeah so uh that
being said let me read a little bit they
say Americans are growing more skeptical
about the safety and effectiveness of
vaccines and politicians from left and
right are echoing these fears in their
campaigns to win the White House polling
this week shows that while most voters
trust shots for Co 19 MMR and other bugs
Millions more have changed their minds
in recent months and no longer see them
as safe the surveys come as health
Chiefs worn of rampant online
misinformation linking injections with
death and autism and that ior macton an
antiparasitic drug typically Us in
animals can treat Co 19 again don't take
medical advice from a news organization
either despite these warnings and their
implications for public health two
politic Ians are building vaccine
skepticism into their 2024 campaign it's
a santis and it's RFK but here's here's
the image look at rfk's face it's the
most hideous
angry so here's here's some questions
they they asked uh is the co 19 vaccine
safe in August of 2022 73% said yes and
18% said no as of October 2023 66% say
yes and 24% say no that's really
interesting they ask do you know someone
personally who died from side effects of
the coid 19 vaccine 24% said yes 69%
said no they ask is increased vaccine
use linked to kids getting autism 10%
said yes in April of 2021 as of October
this year 16% say yes and then there
here's a big one if there was a major
class action lawsuit against
pharmaceutical companies from for
vaccine side effects How likely would
you be to join the lawsuit 24% very
likely 18% somewhat likely not very
likely 22 and not likely at all 25 with
11 not sure the plurality is not likely
and uh they ask is I vered an effective
treatment at in September of 21 10% said
yes as of this month 26% said yes and I
want to stress for the of the time I am
just reading polls calm down YouTube
yeah not all vaccines are the same and
it's not fair to classify them as such
well tested medicine is very different
than untested medicine I like not having
polio the sure and and the main point
Point here is what is Shifting the
American perspective on this issue well
let's first find out how many people got
pulled here this is an important aspect
of this one because if it's just a
thousand people then I'm I'm going to
stop reading Daily Mail like that is a
gross miscat categorization of one in
four Americans that's a good point it
could be it could be a a highly biased
to 1500 people I think it's uh it's r m
reports and the anenberg public policy
Center at the UN of the University of
pen
wow R M's usually pretty good but r m
and uh University of Pennsylvania if it
was just r m I'd say r m gets a lot
right you know we'll see the both of
them together I say okay that's really
interesting again this is not a poll
about whether or not they vaccines
actually cause issues it's something is
Shifting the perspective of the American
population this is going to play a big
role I'm wondering however you know when
Luke said Trump was bad on vaccines and
lockdowns so RFK Jr may pull from him
yeah but Biden was worse Biden and
Democrats were 10 times more into
lockdowns and and and vaccin stuff than
Trump yeah but Trump was in when all the
worst stuff happened when it came to the
lockdowns at least I guess he was he was
the he was the first guy said we're
goingon to shut down for a couple weeks
so and I think you know because you
mentioned how RFK Jr and Trump are very
different ideologically but I mean so
many people who vote I mean just this is
just people I know who voted for Trump
they're not like uh ideological really
they just go in and vote Trump because
they don't like the other person like a
lot of people voted like that so if they
see RFK Jr and he's really good on this
issue and this is a big thing just Co in
general really affected so many people
you know so if he's good on it that
might just be enough for people um I
think that that's an issue that could
flip a lot of trump voters I'm just
really
curious what do you think is causing
this shift in the American public's
perception I mean the corporate press
has been insistent on vaccines and and
and you know we hear as good stewards of
of of
we don't break any of these YouTube
rules how could these people possibly
hold these views I think that it's the
fact that people mistrust Authority you
know trust in the in the media and Trust
in the government had been going down
for a long time prior to coid and Co
just annihilated a lot of people's trust
there's a lot of people that that are
horribly embarrassed by the the way that
they supported the government that they
they believe things that the news said
and I think that that this is the the
the result of that if you have a society
that generally has a declining in trust
and a and honestly we are more cynical
than we've ever been you know it's like
Being Earnest is now looked at as
something to be mocked and so believing
the what the news tells you is is
something that will get you mocked
nowadays if you say oh I believe if you
have enough followers on Twitter you can
say I believe anyone anything it could
be anything at all and someone's going
to say you're wrong and you're dumb for
believing it there is an there is this
there is this impulse that people have
to be the the one person that has the
inside track and so people are afraid to
believe things they're afraid to admit
that they believe things because they're
going to get mocked they're going to get
called out there they going to be people
that say you're dumb for believing that
didn't you know how could you believe
that I mean I see it all the time on in
my Twitter feed oh how could you believe
that you know this and how could you not
so I think that that disincentivizes
people to believe anything they're
afraid to say that they believe anything
they're afraid to say oh I I think this
is actually true and they don't know
where to go to get information that they
feel like they that should be trusted
well let me uh let me piggyback off of
that did this article even link the
study to the poll or are they just like
a poll said one theyi I don't even trust
this story that they're I think they're
lying I don't even think it's they cited
rest M and university did they link to
it but what do you mean like to the
Cross tabs yeah like show me how many
people they pulled if they pulled a
thousand people and and saying that
extra to 350 million I'm going to be
direct when you say that there's like a
shift here like has people has there
really been polls asking this question
before you know we don't really know if
this reflects like a shift I I they it
looks like they had previous polls
asking the same question oh yeah you're
right now that aside the let me let me
see if I can pull up the the cross tabs
that aside I think that rushing this the
co vaccine the warp speed thing tweaked
a lot of people like that was that was
like I'm afraid for my life because of
Co and I'll do anything you say
mentality and then when we saw rises in
like myocarditis that's like
terrifying yeah and Trump still like
brags about warp speed right when they
ask him about it he says you know how
proud of he literally brags about
anything Poss something I kind of wanted
to ask you guys about cuz I know Tim
like you're I don't know if you consider
yourself like a Maga guy but no um I'm
voting for Trump yeah uh he's far from
perfect but he's the best it just seems
like there's a pretty big distinct like
difference between the the Maga movement
and the things that Trump actually says
now uh but I know he represents
something more so RFK Jr I got to say he
was a big disappointment um because you
know I'm kind of a single issue type of
guy and he came out really strong on
Ukraine you know very well and then uh
people started calling him sorry 1500
adults yeah that's this it's just such a
disingenuous title of the article 1500 I
mean that's what do you mean poll finds
mm poll finds Fair Point you should have
said one in four of 1500 P like that's
not 350 Milli PS are typically like a,
to
150000 actually above average consider
that yeah you're right I consider that
it's highly manipulative it's it's just
an absolute waste of a that is it is
most disingenuous misleading tit say
that one in four Americans think it when
they pulled 1500 people Ian I don't
think you understand how pull I
understand completely how they work and
they're massively manipulative how many
they are manip most people understand
that they're not trying to they're not
supposed to be but the way the article
phrased it makes it extremely
manipulative but the point that I'm
making is most people understand that if
you are talking about polls you're not
talking about a poll of a 100,000 people
like they the Civic actually what was
that civic.com they have polls that
because they're so expansive there's
300,000 people yeah crazy good on them
but still most most polls like they're
not hitting you know but but this was a
shock title to get clicks it's Daily
Mail I mean junk junk news it's a Ras M
and and uh uh what is it the uh uh I
want to get the name right the uh
anenberg public policy Center so the way
polls are done is through there's a
scientific polling method where they
take a wide range of individuals they
Whittle down their their networks
there's uh bad things in huge margins of
Errors when when it's done improperly
but you basically try and create a
cross-section of
America isolate it down to the key
demographic areas where you notice these
ideological shifts and then pull a
thousand people and then figure out what
the percentages are and then try and
like that's it's it's normal and and and
you can you can argue there's a margin
of error in these things but right 3,00%
margin of error
what were you going to say I felt like
you were I interrupted you on accident
oh no I was just wondering it wasn't
really related I was just wondering what
you guys think of RFK Jr I mean have you
had him on here I like I like the fact
that he canceled on us oh did he I like
the fact that he's countered to the
narrative that the government puts out I
think that he's terrible on literally
everything except for vaccines yeah I
would say so again with the foreign
policy like he was he's very good on
Ukraine and he explains it well
interviews people uh you know he had his
own podcast he was interviewing people I
know this guy named Ben ablo who wrote a
book called How the West brought War to
Ukraine it's like a very short book that
came out right after the invasion
explaining how the US provoked it so he
interviewed him and he really
understands the issue but when it comes
to Israel people smear him you know they
they called him an anti-semite and he
just went all in on Israel and when this
thing happened it's just like he says
that the US needs to support an Israeli
sustained military campaign I need to
isue a clarification this is the dat
comes from two different polls r m and
enberg did different polls they're just
being mentioned in the same article you
got the RAS M was 1500 the other one uh
no no no uh 1500 1,110 was was r m okay
r m was actually one of the most
accurate polls in I think 2016 and 2018
I think I think consistently actually
when when the polling data comes out
showing how many people voted R muen
almost always Nails it for the record I
really really like accurate polling like
if you can get 10,000 people and you get
an accurate read out of what those
10,000 people think maybe you can be
like you know the isue is this city if r
m does five polls and then they say
here's here's here's what people are
saying 51% 49% then the election happens
and they go yeah it was they were right
5149 how how about that and they do it
five times then they come with another
poll I'm like okay I I I I'll lean
towards believing them Ian I just want
to push back a little bit on what you
said if the if you're dealing with a
country with 330 million people why is
10,000 acceptable and and 15 no I'm
saying in a small town of 10,000 and you
pull all 10,000 people I like those kind
of plls or even if there's like maybe
15,000 people and you pull 10,000 of
them you need like 70 or 80 it's
accurate you need an if you really if
you want to come out and make a
statement that one in four Americans
believe something you better P at least
90% of them right you're not asking for
a poll you're asking for an election
looking for a real poll not these junk
polls aren't the best you know polls are
kind of the best you have when it comes
to the things you're looking to find out
when it comes to like election polling
they're not part they're they're better
lazy they're the only like they're like
just cuz that's how it's always been
done like just deal with it kind of
mentality well you're saying this just
like the best we can do we should impr
I'm saying it's just when it comes to
you know especially elections when you
like it is kind of your best indication
of where people are at is polling and
and the question is are the has the
polling organization been accurate in
the past and then if we look at rest M
and find that they typically are very
accurate you discrediting them because
you don't like pulling methodology makes
no sense I discredit them because they
pulled 1100 people and then they claimed
to speak for 33 no the article did I
think you know if you're saying that
they should just pull more people I
think that's a 100% And most pulling
most polls actually say 47 people of
those poed said yeah or that's what they
should say not the shock the shock
statement you're complaining about a
news organization not the polling
institutions no I think you know there
speaking of polls there was just a poll
conducted by I forget the name of the
place but it was about Israel and Gaza
and it said the majority of Americans
support a ceasefire it said the majority
of Republicans do which like I almost
didn't believe it uh you know I think
that a lot of Americans do want to
ceasefire but to like it was like 80% of
Democrats and 56% of Republicans you
know they pulled like, 1500 people it's
a Trum Trump people don't want war yeah
a lot of yeah you're right I think a lot
of the ordinary Trump people don't want
war even if it is Israel but
unfortunately the magga politicians seem
to uh favor it I think one issue well I
I don't want to derail another issue I
have with polling is uh and this is a
little bit off off basis that I feel
like it is a self-fulfilling prophecy
sometimes if you see if they pull people
and they're like 80% want this then
people see that and they'll be like yeah
me too like that that can kind of that
that's why the their political polls
will often try and skew in favor their
politician to convince people that our
guy's the winner because people want to
vote for the winner so weird if you see
the polls the election polls right now I
mean Trump is leading the pack still by
so much
so that indication like we don't know
the exact what the exact vote would
actually be but from constant polls
showing him so far ahead it gives you an
idea I got a question for you we've been
looking at these polls uh RFK entering
the race as an independent do you think
that he pulls more votes away from Trump
or from Biden I think Trump I actually
do think Trump uh again because just you
know the Trump the average Trump voter
might not be so ideologically drawn to
Trump uh more of a I know so many people
that voted for Trump in 2016 it was just
a vote against The Establishment uh same
thing in 2020 just a lot of people that
didn't like Biden I also knew a lot of
people that didn't vote for him that did
it because they were kind of sick of it
but I think this Co issue again when it
comes to Americans issues that really
affect them I mean this is something
that really affected Americans uh me
personally I you know my wife's business
closed down we moved out of this city we
you know changed our whole life and it's
something that people are going to
remember you know this is this was a
very serious time in in in America you
know it's kind of like if you think back
on it you know I was living in Brooklyn
at the time with the lockdowns and it
was just looking back like it was so
insane and everybody went along with it
and I saw Andrew Cuomo when I would go
get a coffee on the TV with his nipples
sticking out telling us to stay in our
houses and it was crazy and I was so
angry about it Angry enough that we left
and you know I'm fortunate enough that I
was okay you know my wife's business
closing down we were fine we were able
to get out move out to the country but a
lot of people don't didn't have that
option so you know I think he could
definitely pull some Trump voters that
still feel that anger about what
happened in 2020 yeah man now what I
would love to talk about is the vaccine
the co vaccine or the series of Co
vaccines I I don't want to make start
going too hard on it on YouTube I know
that YouTube is requested that we don't
you know spla our opinions about it I
would love to because I think this is
just so many people were traumatized by
this experience of the co vaccine or the
co virus and then the vaccination you
know I left New York before this
happened you had to show them your
vaccination papers to go into a
restaurant I mean that is
insane that is stuff that the antivaxers
were saying a few decades ago that
people were like you not even a few
decades ago not long before that people
were like that's crazy that never 2020
they were like they're going to start
doing these passports I was like shut up
no they're not and they did they tried
they live I can't imagine it they tried
doing the app and nobody would do it
they wanted a social credit score so you
know what's
interesting get uh so K Jr Israel so
that model what New York City did and I
think other cities did it I think DC
might have did it for a little while you
know the vaccine passport was modeled on
Israel's green pass Israel like was very
you know vaccine mandate and lockdowns
and stuff and I believe it was called
the green pass so kind of one of the
most intrusive things that they did to
us was based on Israel's model China on
the other hand they had their uh
lockdowns that were really insane but
they actually they tried to implement
some sort of vaccine mandate in Beijing
and people were like no we're not doing
that and then they gave up so it's kind
of interesting just the differences uh
in the countries like it's not something
you would really expect that you would
just assumed China had like a vaccine
mandate but they didn't like in that
sense of you have to walk in and show
them your card or scan something um but
he based off Israel's uh model wow I was
thinking the other day how funny it was
and maybe it's funny strange not funny
haha that it was Co they were like it's
so dangerous that you have to get tested
to find out if you even have it and I'm
like okay really did I'm proud of so is
that I've never taken a CO test and that
wasn't really like intentional but I
just never did I took one and I tickled
the back of my nose and I was just
sneezing and blowing all this snot out
dude it felt so good I was outside doing
it I like oh yeah rolling around maybe I
should take one that sounds it felt
really nice okay that's awful yeah so
now everyone knows but back to politics
rough we I I I don't I don't see uh I
think RFK Jr plls from both Trump and
Biden but two to one Biden from Trump
Biden two think so okay yeah because RFK
Jr is a is a uh he's a liberal yeah his
core is liberal it's true he's Kennedy
he's got the Kennedy name know he's
running on that Ian's pointed out when
he talks about his family that his
family would not vote for Trump they
would vote for Biden they might vote for
RFK I think that's just like a really
simple way of breaking down what this
might be they did vote for Biden I don't
know what they're up to these days I I
should talk to about it I mean Biden's
mental degradation is become very
apparent if the poll is for Democrats
Five Points towards RFK meaning your
average person has a 95% chance of
voting for Joe Biden that still means 5%
vote for RFK Jr whereas the poll for
Trump supporters is like one what are
your feelings on Viv
ramaswami uh he says you know a lot of
good things but I think his foreign
policy he's pretty off base uh on some
things with you know Taiwan for instance
he he wants to commit to defending
Taiwan but he also says things like oh
once we get semiconductor Independence
then we're not going to uh you know
worry about Taiwan anymore but he's
still saying that you know to deter War
we should you know commit to war with
Taiwan and also his plan to end the
Ukraine war he's like I'm going to get
Putin to sever his military alliance
with China and that's how we're going to
end it it's not really a realistic plan
you know they don't really have a formal
military Alliance they've been building
one up and doing drills and stuff uh but
also just they're not going to go for
that I mean trust has been destroyed
between the west and Russia you know
there's going to have to be some uh real
good faith negotiations and you know
trying to just get something like that
like China and Russia have really built
up their trade relationship in recent
years and they're very relying on each
other now they're not just going to give
that up for the US that could change in
eight four or eight years somebody will
come in and say you know what forget
that we're going to move you know move
NATO into Ukraine forget that guarantee
we gave you we need to rebuild trust
before you could do something like that
yeah new Administration is a is a
definitely a big thing like Putin's not
a dumb guy and he also tries to play it
off of Richard Nixon going to China and
shaking hands with MAO uh but what Nixon
uh had this the sinos Soviet split to
capitalize they were already enemies the
Soviet Union and and communist China at
that point um that's not the situation
right now with Putin and xiin ping you
know they're they're best buddies right
now so it's a very different time and uh
you know I actually spoke with uh Chaz
Freeman about this who he was in the US
government in various positions but he
was actually Nixon's interpreter when he
went to Ma and he agreed that you know
the idea that it's it's anything similar
to like that is just is just off base um
so you know I think kind of there's
other ways to argue for ending the
Ukraine war just the fact that it's not
an American interest that it's every day
that we continue it it's very dangerous
we're spending all this money we're
going bankrupt I think that should
really be the argument and we see that
argument from other Republicans do you
think it's just to declare like a white
piece and Seed the Eastern donbass to
Russia um what I think should happen
yeah uh it's tough to say I mean um you
know right now I think really the US
just has to end it and make Ukraine
negotiate something and whatever that is
and you know realistically at this point
Russia's not going to give that
territory up um and you know it's it's
the donbass and zaper roia and caran you
know we're not we shouldn't be risking
nuclear war for those territories you
know it shouldn't have gotten to this
point it didn't have to get to this
point but now that it's at this point we
need to end this thing we need to end
this thing tomorrow because again we
could wake up and be at war with Russia
again assassinations in Russia with you
know CIA trained groups killing people
it's it you know the fact that we're at
this point is really unbelievable well I
would love to just drill down into the
philosophy of what's going on in the
Middle East in uh Israel and Palestine
it is however 9:31 I think we're about
to take some super chat we are going to
Super chats YouTube's been giving us the
business though the super chats aren't
loading properly load me but it's fine
it's fine we'll figure it out because uh
this is what we do here we we we uh we
do it we're going to pull up these super
Jets and there they are they're back all
right let's go shaky own says is Steven
Marsh's next book titled Canadian
Delicacies 1,1 excuses for eating boot
leather that's brutal I I uh here here's
my assessment of Stephen I think he's a
good dude uh the first time we had him
on it was an excellent conversation I
think he and I can see the same thing
however he's coming from The
Establishment perspective and we're
coming from a moderate perspective and
so this is one of things we tried
bringing up on the show the culture War
podcast is that he said something like
there are more seditionists on the right
than the left I said what's your metric
for that he goes court cases and then I
said okay where the court cases around
529 he goes what's that I'm like okay
that's my point if you if if if his
argument is it is not that bad that
far-left extremists were throwing fire
bombs at the White House Set set set
fire to a church and they rushed Trump
into an emergency bunker and that
doesn't warrant investigations and
arrest it's not Insurrection it's not
sedition well then you're coming from a
very biased perspective and I'm not
asserting either I didn't say there was
more or on the left or the right I think
I think it may it may be fair to say
there's more on the left but they're
less extreme and there are very very few
on the right but they are very extreme
and so uh but so that means his view of
what's going on when he sees you know
something happening that leads us to
Civil War his perspective is skewed by
an establishment perspective whereas I
think ours is certainly skewed by an
anti EST anti-establishment perspective
but as Phil pointed out with Jonathan
Height's research the right knows the
left is thinking the left does not know
what the right is thinking so we are a
more moderate probably in many ways
right leaning uh uh for a variety of
reasons basic because the left doesn't
come on the show I think the people on
this show are are fairly moderate but
that means we have a more holistic view
of what's going on and why and Steph's
more biased in that regard he thinks
he's not I think he is and then he says
we're biased but it's actually really
simple if he's coming from a left
liberal perspective we are to the right
of him because we're in the middle and
so he doesn't know what you know that's
what I think but I think he's a good we
had a lot of fun he played poker he's
really good as well I really like you
guys don't have you guys have leftist on
here once in a while right but they
don't come on well you had Max
Blumenthal Rec they do yeah but Max is a
good dude yeah like many of these that I
like a lot but there so he's he he he
was honest and he was like impressively
honest with his views and his his his
his uh Pro Palestine bias he said but
he's telling us the truth
he said like it's it we I get it I'm
like you're allowed to be in favor of
Palestine you're allowed to even be in
favor of Hamas I just don't like that so
be honest about it so I appreciate these
leftists in New York cheering for Hamas
I I'm I I appreciate that they're
telling me they feel that way I mean how
many of them are are they really
cheering for Hamas in New York
literally almost every rally they're
cheering for Hamas I know that there's
again you know we talked about this
before the show I know people involved
in these rallies and stuff and
explicitly cheering for Hamas Yeah but I
there's a lot I I think that might that
might just be being Amplified because I
know again a lot of Jewish anti-war
activists organizing these things
leading and that means your the people
you know organizing things are handing
microphones to people to cheer on Hamas
what what do you think like when you see
like the like the the leader of Hamas
talking about like killing all the Jews
What leader of Hamas the spokesman that
that was on recently saying keep
fighting I mean yeah that's not the
point because the point I'm making is
this at almost all of these rallies in
New York like Times Square specifically
I'm not talking about like Grand Central
where it's people sitting down uh you
have a woman get up and say our freedom
fighters parag glided into Israel and
fired 5 thou okay that's Hamas and then
you had one guy said our freedom
fighters kidnapped a whole bunch of
hipsters I'm sure they're doing great
but there's so many of these I don't
think there's as many as you think I
again I think this is being Amplified
cuz the there's like an internet
propaganda war going on I think that's
look I mean you see the big marches the
the the people rer that means that from
Jordan the Jordan River to the
Mediterranean Sea Palestinians will have
equal rights that's what that that's
where that came I don't that one second
that is that is like defund the police
doesn't really mean defund the police it
absolutely meant so this is so so from
the rivy you're saying does not mean the
abolition of the Jewish State uh it
could mean it to some people if they
want one state that's not a Jewish state
that that that could mean that it means
different things to different people I
know the lud founding document says
basically from Jordan to the Sea you
know it will be Israeli uh Sovereign
territory so there but there are there
are Arabs in in the canit right there
are Arabs that are in the in the
parliament in Israel if the
Palestinians had the had control over
Israel and it was Palestine there
wouldn't be Jews I mean that's I don't
buy I and I don't I mean I understand
there's people that are going to say oh
they wouldn't blah blah blah I don't buy
it for a second and the reason I don't
is because there are an if Hamas right
if the attack on the 7eventh if Hamas
were like super soldiers they would have
killed everybody but they're not they're
not but there are enough people that
hate all the Jews in in the Middle East
to kill all the Jews there's like 16
million let's slow down Max brought this
up he said they want to return to their
ancestral Homeland right okay so what
does that mean if if Israel removes the
barriers of Gaza and says everyone is
now free to move about the country what
happens what do I think would happen if
Israel took down all of the fencing on
Gaza and said everyone in Gaza you are
now free to move out the country yeah I
mean I'm not sure what would happen but
I know would would the people that Max
said want their ancestral land back try
to get it back I think some people might
something it's a realistic thing like I
I agree that the kind of the right of
return that the people the children of
refugees in God that want to go back to
you know their homes that their parents
or Grandparents were kicked out of is
not really a realistic thing but I mean
we're talking about a peace deal
essentially that that wouldn't happen if
them just opening the fence and letting
them them go I'm not saying need to
negotiate real that's not the point the
point the more that this keeps going on
and they keep killing children Ian now
you're shifting away from what I'm
talking about my point is when
protesters say from The River To The Sea
you are giving them the benefit of Doubt
when what you're giving them makes
literally no sense as to their own
arguments if their argument is a right
to return to land which currently has
houses and families living in it then
you would argue that the the nicest way
to to view it is that they will come
enter those homes and say we live here
now too okay that that absolutely will
will result in violence yeah I mean the
thing is like when it comes to a one
state solution the the what the things
that Israel is doing in the West Bank
right now they're still kicking people
out of their homes especially since
things popped off on October 7th you
know a thousand Palestinians have been
kicked out of their houses by by S here
saying that but you're talking I'm
talking about leftist right now if they
just open it but leftists but we're
we're I'm talking about protests in the
United States yeah where they're either
explicitly defending Hamas because this
what we're talking about I said you've
got people Pro protesting in support
ofas I think that's a very small
minority and then I said what does River
to the Sea me because you have high
school students chanting it and if the
argument is Palestinians will have equal
rights that would mean people in Gaza
can freely move about the country
correct and the right of return is
explicitly they want the land back which
means you have no the River from from
the river to the sea in the nicest
interpretation means Mass violence in
Israel no it doesn't how do you get your
land back are they going to go and and
file they going to well that's assuming
that that's the deal that okay you guys
can have your houses back that's not
going to be the deal they're not just
going to let people okay you could go
now go run you know so the argument
would be that from The River To The Sea
just literally means they want to try
and and get go to Tel Aviv it means
equal rights yeah they want to go to the
beach that's something kids in the West
Bank always says that they want to go
see the beach they can't go see the
beach they live under military
occupation their entire life is under
control of the Israeli military and you
know we talk about what happened on
October 7th um you know there was an
attempt at nonviolent protests in 2018
and 2019 called the Great March of
return where they just walked to the
Border fence and some people were
throwing rocks and lighting stuff on
fire but mostly see Max didn't mention
that it was an unarmed protest Max said
they started shooting protesters of
course he didn't mention no but they
were shooting protesters they were
shooting unarmed people they shot they
shot somebody in a wheelchair they shot
women uh Medics very clearly Medics
journalists they killed hundreds of
people my my uh simple thing for all
this is I literally as it pertains to
American policy don't care about the
moral arguments of war in foreign lands
because the argument is we can't
adjudicate this for them we are not the
World Police I agree yeah and so
whenever it devolves into like yeah but
Israel are guys I'm just like you know
what America's not supposed to be
involved you were asking those questions
but my my I'm not asking the questions
about the what what Israel is doing in
the West Bank versus Palestine I'm
asking about Americans here at rallies
are are are protesting in support of
Hamas and you said I think it's a small
group my argument is if if if the
argument is only a small group of people
our government is helping Israel blow up
apartment buildings and kill children
our are governments doing that you guys
are worried about you know the war on
terror being turned in on the right wing
I
mean looks like I'm saying is why are
you focusing on these college kids
chanting this stuff when people in New
York City are not College these are
these see this is this is my point this
is what it devolves into my attitude my
argument is there are people in the
United States who are advocating for
extreme uh uh look if if if if a propal
comes to me let meish if a pro Palestine
activist comes to me and says from The
River To The Sea and then they're like
we will return to our land and we will
have this back I go okay and they go
help help they're killing our kids I'll
be like bro like what do you what
there's a war going on where Hamas just
killed a bunch of kids and now Israel's
killing more civilians because they're
bombing things but you came out and
cheered for it you can't come to me and
cheer for the murder of civilians and
then be angry that Israel is killing
civilians because I'm like you guys are
in a war and one side has power it has
nothing to do with me don't cheer for
civilian death and then cry about
civilian death later I don't believe
youe I agree with that I don't think
they should cheer civilian death again I
do think that's a small minority and the
problem is the same argument is made by
people in support of Israel where
they're like Israel's not trying to kill
civilians they were attacking and they
retaliating take out commanders and and
leaders and now you're you're you're
you're highlighting these civilians no
no all civilian deaths are bad yeah the
so here's where Israel wins the pr War
oh one thing I want to mention so you
had rectenwald on the other day and he
mentioned that there was some evidence
that on October 7th and the fighting
that happened a few days after IDF
killed IDF killed some Israelis and he
didn't have a citation for that so
that's actually something that Max
Blumenthal covered at the grey Zone but
he cited Israeli media and again this is
just evidence that some of the civilians
might have been killed by the Israeli
military that's so so here's the issue I
had with that not that he was wrong it's
that if he said there's a there's been
reports it's possible when the IDF came
in fog of War they didn't know who was
shooting who and they there was friendly
fire I'd say well that happens all the
time of course he said they were they
were they were bombing uh houses and and
and shooting people but to come out and
be like the IDF was killing their own
people and and bombing houses it's just
like I don't think he said I mean uh
that's I I just didn't get that vibe
from the way Reon said it but maybe I'm
just biased cuz I so so here's my view I
am I am the United States I don't mean
like I am literally thees I mean like me
here I am a US citizen and I see the
Israeli side the Palestinian side and
I'm like man I see civilians dying this
is bad two things first uh the left and
the prop Palestinian side has lied about
too much I'm not I'm not a historian on
on Israel Gaza they said a hospital was
bombed lie they said that ref it wasn't
a lie the hospital wasn't bombed well it
was they said it was decimated they said
the building was Lev who said what when
that that report happened that night a
lot of people a lot of people said a lot
of things was it 500 people died and a
hospital was decimated and then the
whole conversation was what could have
blown up a hospital and there was like
oh it was a parking lot yeah yeah so
then then the refugee camp Oh actually
it's not a refugee camp they are
refugees technically oh right
technically but it actually a city there
was a lot of civilians there and the IDF
admitted it there's a reason why talking
about lying like if we're if you're not
going to trust them because they lie all
the time the the Israeli government also
lies all the time you are correct and
here's the problem as me in the United
States who not a historian the the the
people on the left in sport of Palestine
lie about these things and then I asked
the question is is Israel being honest
you just said Israel admitted to bombing
a refugee Village so what what Israel is
winning in the pr war is they're saying
I'm sorry that this is happening it's
War it's terrible we did this yes and
I'm like wow they admitted it then
Israel says we are desperately trying
not to kill civilians and I say okay I
hear that then you get people on the pro
pro Palestine side in New York cheering
for the killing of civilians and then
coming out be like help out they're
killing civilians Hamas is also saying
that they didn't mean to kill civilians
that you know so if you're going to
argue that Israel come out is saying
that they didn't mean to kill civilians
that's what Israel's saying and they're
slaughtering civilians right now look at
What's happen but you you did say Hamas
is saying that they did not me comp to
what he said yeah want make they said it
was in the crossa the Hezbollah guy you
know he's not Hamas obviously I don't
believe Hamas okay that's fine because
you believe either Phil Phil sett not
that's that's that's that's what they
said right they admitted that civilians
were killed no no no but settlers are
not civilians this is an argument made
by a yell Professor to justify the
attacks hamat committed my point is
simply this I'm not here to tell you who
is right or who is wrong I'm telling you
the pr war is being won by Israel
because Israel is is I think right now
they're losing that's only on the
internet I mean I don't think so I mean
we had uh when we were talking to Steven
Marsh earlier he said you realize left
died this month because of what because
of Palestine because of because of the
activists tearing down the Flyers
because uh uh or I I believe that was
the larger insinuation is because of
what we're seeing with uh like Amy
Schumer for instance reposting campus
reform like a conservative campus
publication we are seeing mainstream
celebrities now posting right-wing
things and actually saying wow we were
wrong about the left I can't believe we
were so wrong because of how many people
have Che like BLM posting the paraglider
yeah stupid we definitely got to go to
Super Chat so okay but I would just say
you know with this we see the same
tactics that the left deploys when it
comes to Israel criticism of Israel is
always called anti-semitic I agree and
you know it's they're annoying we
haven't called anyone anti-semitic
like it's really annoying when they're
like if you're criticizing Israel you're
antii no no no no no no if there's a war
going on and someone's doing bad things
in war criticize the F out of them I
don't care who they are I I I I roast
the United States all day today about
the horrible things the US does it's
just that I ain't
Israel if you're hanging with people
that say gas the Jews you're probably
should should go reason I got be honest
if if you're hanging with people who are
saying glass Gaza you got a problem with
the reason why I focus my criticism on
Israel same thing with Ukraine is
because my government is uh enabling
this funding this backing this Israel
probably wouldn't be able to go as hard
as they are without if the US didn't
send all these aircraft carers to the
Middle East we're completely enabling
this and again to the people that are
being killed they're being killed by
Israel and the United States and the US
is sending troops on the ground and we
probably already have special forces in
Gaza but let's let's let's read more
Super chats otherwise we're just gonna
all right David Ray says You must have
JP Sears on your show ASAP uh JP Sears
has a standing invitation to come on any
one of our shows or even just to come
here and hang out and have a slice of
pizza because we're big fans he's
awesome um but as I always say it's it's
you know like we we tried getting Jen
yuger on the show for a long time and he
he wouldn't do it and I'm like well he
hosts his own show come on he's not
going to cancel his show to come here
but he's running for president so he did
we're happy he did if JP Sears ever has
time or he's on the East Coast we'd love
to have him but I I'm not surprised
people who host shows are too busy to
come and be on my show typically the
people who come on the show do different
are not hosts and they have day jobs
where it's like oh I can swing by that
night and do the show but uh you know
we'd love to have him we'd love to have
him all right let's uh here we go
Delamar says forklift gate is Real Texas
sued and got a temporary injunction
against the US government to stop
messing with the wire the forklift was
part of the case wow was it a forklift I
think it was a backloader though it
wasn't a forklift it looked like a back
end loader yeah yeah I know about
forklift it's funny because I nobody
knows what they're called and I I just I
Googled it like a week ago cuz I'm like
what what what do we call those things
they not cranes yeah we back in right
exactly the tobacco yeah backo back back
right my kid's learning my 2-year-old
like knows all the construction vehicles
like all the kid shows on YouTube it's
like all tractors and stuff it's kind of
cool check out open source ecology build
your own yeah yeah shout out to Marson
jabowski all right let's go uh frag null
says timcast 2024 and yeah my payday is
your payday wo uh I want good silicon so
Taiwan silicon forges is good to protect
Talk Amongst yourself no no Bolton the
mustache uh we have an Eclectic bunch at
timcast I'm very proud of that like I'm
I'm particularly uh proud of the fact
that OD and Cassandra are friends and
boy are they on the other sides of of
the political spectrum elad is our
resident Bolton bro neocon he calls
himself this but but he's yeah but but
when he when he interviews the
protesters he's very fair just ask him a
question lets him answer he doesn't
insert anything he does a good job and
then Cassandra is as anti-war and as
isolationist as you can be and hates
Israel
yeah she's hardore I mean it's great I
think the diversity of thought is really
good to have yeah the the this company
is not uh made upon the ideological
goals of like a military operation or or
a single news event it is simply I mean
I got to be honest what Cassandra and
alad represent is quite literally the
ideological goal of of one of one of the
ideological goals of of me and this
company is that people are allowed to
have different opinions and discuss
those opinions and be mad at each other
but we all live together and we get
along so actually they're exemplifying
what I think is important in this
country that we we maintain the ability
for for descent it used to be a lot more
common I know so uh I disagree with
cassandre on a lot of things and uh you
know I've talked to her about it but I'm
like dude I'm not going to stop being
friends with someone because of our
opinions on a foreign war I mean that's
the craziest thing ever it's funny
people were like getting the tweets of
people who be like like you know don't
go on timcast anymore because
Cassandra's opinions and I'm like oh
okay dude like you you people people
like tagging you in her tweets I know I
know I love it like bro I just want I
just want to stress like I've known
Cassandra for a decade she's one of my
best friends her opinion on war in a
foreign land is not going to affect our
friendship and I'm not going to fire her
over that it's like one thing one it's a
big thing it's foreign policy and people
are allowed to have opinion same thing
with elad he we I yelled at him like got
we got into a yelling match because we
were we were arguing about war and he
was for war saying he wasn't for war
he's like I don't want war but we must
win it and I'm like we got into it heavy
on one of the members only segments and
I'm like I apologize after I'm like I
sorry I got so heated you know but I'm
I'm glad we can have that you know
that's what it's all about all right
let's read some more all right Paul
thongam says Tim to have the people
better understand China please have
people from the YouTube channel China
uncensored on you see I was mentioning
we get these messages all the time
absolutely absolutely I'll just say uh
you know Cassandra let's let's have try
uncensor him should David Zang uh La 86
and also serpent Za All Good China
speaking of China uh my friend Joseph
soless Mullen he writes at the
libertarian Institute he just put out a
book about China called the fake China
threat kind of uh trying to go against
some of the war propaganda so go check
that out are you familiar with fuity
trap yes so that's that's the general
it's I wouldn't call it the Layman's
understanding because it's a little bit
more esoteric but the simple idea is the
minutia doesn't matter what matters is
we are facing a rising economic threat
to the United States the United States
is not going to tolerate that yeah and
and you know but we do have a
choice I mean I prefer the uh the the
trumpian but another thing about this
book sorry uh that uh soless Mullen gets
into you know he's a Libertarian it's
from kind of a more right-wing
perspective is about the trouble that
China has economically and one of the
best arguments in the book is if you
look at China's backyard they have a big
border with India Japan I mean these are
big uh countries that don't want uh
China to expand in the region um so they
have a lot to deal with in their own
neighborhood so there's a lot of reasons
just not to be so afraid of China and
that's what he lays out in the book
pretty well the lion says a culture War
episode with LA 86 and serpent Za would
be pretty dope yes uh you want you want
you want to message Lisa uh yes I sort
it out that' be sweet I'd like to see
them as well watch them personally I
think I think next week we might be
doing a debate on Israel yes SC yeah
yeah yeah I'm I'm excited and uh and and
I I believe it's Scott and Will
Chamberlain we normally don't announce
but it's like these are friend these are
friends of the show where Scott Horton
and Will Chamberlain they were going at
on Twitter on X and uh but it's funny
because like you know I talk about how
people have Israel derangement syndrome
and I don't mean I don't mean just
against I mean for or against it like
it's like it's it's hyperpolarized it's
always like one super extreme or the
other and uh people are then stop
talking about I'm like right now the big
news and the threat in the Middle
Eastern region is over Israel we're
going to talk about it it's just it's a
conversation you don't rush which is
part of why the last the 15 minut where
you guys were talking seem so frantic
and kenetic you really it's a long
observant conversation I would recommend
to people you guys know Daryl Cooper
negative uh martyr made podcast oh yeah
yeah he has like a 26h hour series uh
it's called fear and lo Jem Jerusalem or
not East Jerusalem New Jerusalem and it
is
excellent when him on to talk about
Israel I mean he's really good when I
was in uh when I was in Tel Aviv
whenever I would walk out of my hotel
there was a like four foot tall tree
stump like I guess you'd call it a stump
the tree was cut down and there was this
cat just sitting on the every time just
staring at me as I walked out and I'm
like what is this cat this strange Omen
when I was in Jordan I stayed in am man
for a few weeks cat was cool there was a
little red cat that stayed outside my
door and I fed like everybody that
stayed in the place like fed them
there's cats everywhere they love during
uh during the uh elections in Turkey
this is back in I think like 2014 I was
in uh Istanbul we were going from around
different precincts because there was
concern over election fraud and crazy
stuff was going on and this street dog
decided to become friends with us and
come with us everywhere we went I called
him Herman cuz Herman is the name I give
to any animal at any point because it's
just like a generic name you're Herman
now and I got a picture of him it was
really it was so it was so I love turkey
man it's such a it's some Bol so fun but
like the dog basically adopted us and we
were like we got a dog now and he just
walked with us everywhere we went and we
would leave and he would run and walk
with us we didn't give him anything he
just hung out it was it was it was
pretty Co all right here we go JD says
the horseshoe crab blood is drawn while
alive and on board the vessel that
caught it the crab is then released
alive back into the ocean the blood is
studied by universities and they pay
pretty good uh to utilize us commercial
Lobster men to get it I just want to
stress imagine you and your buddies are
hanging out like outside the bar when a
UFO appears over you and beams you up
and then you're like sh to thing going
like what's happening and they plug a
thing and suck your blood out you're
like help me and then they drop you back
down and you're like I swear I swear and
they're like shut up that didn't happen
happen we're literally abducting crabs
and stealing their blood that is exactly
what's happen abducting crabs the crabs
like a big silver thing and above us
came and it pulled me in they're like
get out of here crab dude you're crazy I
wonder what it would cause that cuz I
would go down to like this little Harbor
that was by my house on Long Island and
sometimes there would just be like just
the whole Beach covered in dead
horseshoe crabs
jeez all right all right David M uh uh
malaro says Tim quote supporting Ukraine
is proar also Tim we should invade
Canada
brilliant I am joking about the Canada
Invasion thing it's the cultural
Invasion like the British Invasion of
the Beatles and all that I serious about
invading Alaska because it's it's it's
ours already and we have a lot of
resources there that we could we could
stop worrying about China rare Earths
and and and these things if we just go
to Alaska yep and uh they won't do it
they won't do it that's truth and we
could developing Alaska would be
fantastic alaskans uh we had a bunch
messages saying they'd love it because
it would help expand industry and and
you know build things and boost the
economy it's good stuff they got good
stuff Alaska is very big is Alaska the
biggest state yes yeah it is right yes
it is it's like half the size of the
country or something like that it's I
think it's a third of the mass of the uh
the lower 48 that's crazy that's crazy
man wow Alaska is based AF Deus Flex
says reminder that the barbery wars was
the only reason Thomas Jefferson
purchased a Quran and ilhan Omar used it
to swear herself into office yep oh jeez
that's I'm talking about know thine
enemy man if you're afraid of something
investigate it she used his Quran is
that what it was wow if you're going to
use a Quran that's a good one to use but
but like the reason it exists is not for
the reason it is presumed when she puts
her hand on you know what I mean right
like it's like oh wow he had a Quran he
was studying like I will swear this it
was more so like he was studying because
they were enemies
mhm yep like yeah the guy's like hey
you're an Infidel my book says I can do
this and he goes for real let me see
that that's like I'm going to look at
this for real for real No Cap No Cap
that's exactly what Thomas Jefferson
said okay let's grab another one guad
look says there's a $6,000 Holo
Charizard at the card shop near me
$6,000 wow yeah there was there's a
viral video right now of a guy opening a
Charizard and it's $250,000 or something
I don't know exactly 250,000 yeah I mean
a black lotus is worth more
yeah some of those new Pokemon cards are
going for a lot of money man new ones
well not new ones but here's a trick
with magic the Gathering when a new set
comes out there's usually some cards
that are worth 50 bucks right away
instantly because you'll need them for
the uh uh the top they're called net
decks and so uh when you're playing
competitively in the uh standard format
where it's like I don't know I don't
know how they're doing it these days
five the last five sets or something so
uh a card will come out you it'll be
called like Ian the great and it just
came out they're all over the place but
everybody who wants to build the top
tier deck for competition needs it so
the demand is ridiculously high right
away usually what ends up happening is
or I should say in certain circumstances
this this happened at least uh once to
me you can buy a box of boosters for 150
bucks and you're almost going to you're
going to get one or two and so the
combined value of all the all the the
cards you pull will be greater than the
cost of the Box itself W it's because
the average person does not want to
spend 150 bucks on a bunch of random
cards they want the one single card so
they pay a premium just to get it and
that makes means you can buy a bunch of
boxes crack them all open and turn a
profit yeah and card shops do that
that's what they do they open boxes and
put them in display when I was a kid my
friend's parents did that they just
bought all the Pokemon cards and would
sell the expensive ones and then give us
the N the scraps yeah all right let's uh
grab one last one kcb says the rightwing
has become tolerant and weak we are
being socially engineered to revert back
to being patriotic though uh through
ever increasing oppression recruiting is
way down and the military needs Patriots
the interesting thing is when we were
talking with Steven Marsh earlier he
mentioned you know in his book the last
election like that the it always comes
down to what the military decides to do
and I think that's a really interesting
point if people are resigning their
commissions because of wokeness and the
military is overly woke I think it's
fair to say we know what direction the
military would go in the event of civil
conflict there's part of me that thinks
that the reason the the upper echelon
the the brass if you will uh in the
military are woke is because when you
get to the higher um higher ranks
definitely generals it becomes political
so they're I don't know that they I
don't know that I believe that they
actually believe in the woke stuff so
much as know that you know know the
things that they have to say and the
positions that they have to hold if
they're going to achieve another you
know another if you're going to get
another star if you got one star and you
want a second one you want to get
another you know another uh you want to
get another commission or get a command
or whatever you have to be able to you
have to say the right things and and
have the right opinions all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.net Dave the camp where I give
you the News 5 days a week from a
non-interventionist anti-war perspective
go over there do I tell them to smash It
smash subscribe button just smash smash
every but yeah
Crush Channel and uh subscribe button
anti-war what's the channel called again
it's called anti-war news with Dave the
camp and that's me and I work for
antiwar.com which has been around since
1995 it was founded by Justin Rondo and
Eric Garris unfortunately Justin passed
away in 2019 but he was a genius people
should go back and read everything he
wrote not everything cuz then you don't
really have time for that but he was
great um yeah and I'm really proud to
work for
them awesome I am Phil that remains of
uh Phil that remains on X Phil that
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains you can follow us on
Apple music Spotify Amazon music Pandora
YouTube you know the internet and I'm
Ian cross and it is great to be back
good to to see you guys great to meet
you Dave and uh I want to remind you to
check out gamer Maids the newest show on
uh Tim pool's Network on the timcast
network guess it's all of our Network at
this point and also check out my YouTube
channel if you want to find Solutions
we're about to save the world things are
changing rapidly right now and you can
be a part of the change witness it
understand the technology we're going to
build hydrogen fuel graphine check out
my YouTube channel check out the
interview with James T Dr James tour out
Rice University subscribe like the video
and I'll catch you guys next week yeah
good to have you back again
uh it's been a good week I will be in
the comments in the videos for the last
week I'm going to try and do that and
see if anyone said anything that's cool
and spicy and fun to argue about my name
is surge.com see you next week we will
see you all next week Clips are up
throughout the weekend thanks for
hanging
out